Hallo und herzlich willkommen zur Podcast-Folge UFO 50! Happy Birthday to us! Folge 50! Alles Gutes 50! Wir kennen uns in und auswendig! Hallo, herzlich willkommen! Hallo, herzlich willkommen! Stefan Dietze! Florentin, herzlich willkommen zu dieser fantastischen Folge 50. Es war ein Ritt durch die Wogen der... Was Zehnerfolgen, wie bescheuert die waren. Die Nullerfolgen waren noch gut. Wir gelachen. Sag mal ganz im Ernst, mal so ein ernster Rückblick. Die Nullerfolgen, da war noch so ein bisschen was im Argen, aber war halt experimentell, experimentell freudig. Die Zehnerfolgen, furchtbar. Alles vor Folge 12 habe ich überhaupt gar keine Erinnerung mehr, gar nichts. Folge 12 war furchtbar, ne? Folge 12 war die erste schlechte Folge, danach ging es. Von daher ging es ein bisschen bergab. Ich glaube, was richtig schlecht war, waren die Zwanziger, glaube ich. Es gab irgendeine Dekade, und mittlerweile kann man ja auch, um mal eines der Grössten, auch direkt zu einem der Höhepunkte zu springen, auf der Puffopedia kann man mittlerweile auch die Folgen bewerten. Ehrlich? Man kann Bewertungen abgeben, finde ich auch schlecht, aber... Ich würde gerne das Bewertungstool bewerten. Aber es ist ja zum Beispiel, ich fände es ja zum Beispiel bei anderen Podcasts ganz egoistisch gut, dass wenn man jetzt sagt, so hey, ich würde jetzt gerne Radio Nukular hören, ah, 66 Folgen, gib mir mal die besten drei. So dann sagen ganz viele Fans verschiedene Sachen und so hast du halt einfach eine Bewertung. Es gibt bei Scrubs ja diese grossartige, diese grossartige Tabelle, wo man halt die ganzen IMDb-Scores zusammengerechnet hat. Für jede einzelne Folge. Für jede einzelne Folge, und da gibt es halt eine Folge, die extrem schlechte Bewertung, aber nur eine. Es ist durchgehend wirklich in der neuner Region, wirklich dann in Staffel vier irgendwann geht's einfach so downhill, richtig krass senkrecht runter. Das ist schon hart. Obwohl ich mir die Folge als erstes anschauen würde, einfach nur aus Neugier. Auf jeden Fall, aber ich finde es auch cool, wenn Leute das entdecken, dass sie dann direkt die guten Folgen erwischen. Ich weiß nicht, was da auch noch eine Wundertüte. Aber falls ihr da eine grobe Einschätzung noch habt, welche Folgen gut waren und welche schlecht, oder falls ihr eine Lieblingsfolge habt, dann schreibt das doch einfach bei der Purpopedia, könnt ihr abstimmen und dann können wir auch weitermachen.
Und wir haben lange überlegt, was machen wir für Folge 50?
Der Heissluftballon, ist es die Badewanne, ist es das Bällebad, ist es der Drive-Thru, ist es der Podcast im Auto, ist es im Zug, im ECE, fahren wir irgendwo hin, was machen wir? Wir haben uns die Haare schuppig gekocht. Ich glaube, wir haben die beste
Lösung gefunden. Wir haben einfach
ein bundes Pop-Programm, super Gäste.
Aber wirklich formidablen
Gäste. Ausgelesene Gäste, nicht nebenbei
irgendwie geschnappt, was ihr gerade auf dem Hof rumläuft
oder so. Auf keinen Fall. Richtig gute Gäste,
teilweise Leute, die schon mal da waren,
einer, und
teilweise neue Leute, die es noch nicht in diesem
Podcast gefunden haben. Alle anderen. Alle anderen. Aber ich bin gespannt. Unsere ersten Gäste kennen Florentin schon sehr gut. Hier kommen sie schon herein. Oh, da kommen sie schon herein. Worldwide Wohnzimmer. Worldwide Wohnzimmer, Tünn-TV, Benni und Dennis Wolter. Viel Spaß. Ich glaube, es gibt aber auch billigen Honig, oder? Nee, gibt's nicht. Habe ich geguckt. Es gibt mindestens, also der günstigste kostet 3,50 Euro oder so. Und da habe ich schon gedacht, hä, warum ist das denn so teuer? Bist du ein Honig-Fan? Nee, eigentlich nicht, aber man hat ja so Phasen. Ja. Dann war ich auf der Honigphase, dass übrigens das, wenn überall wo ich hinkomme, als Gast würde ich das haben. Was ich richtig gut finde, ich bin ja, ich bin ja vegan, und deswegen muss ich immer gucken, ob dann irgendwelche so Nussriegeln oder so ein Gedöns drin ist.
Und dann gucke ich hier drauf und die einzige Information zu diesem gesamten Produkt, das man hat, ist das Wort Serviervorschlag in 20 verschiedenen Sprachen.
Aber warum denn ein Riegel? Das ist nur ein Riegel.
Aber das war doch schon in so einer grossen Pappbox, oder nicht? Auf der Pappbox steht dann mehr...
Das kann sein, aber das ist wirklich Serviervorschlag, Suggerimento, die Präsentation, Suggestion, die Präsentation, Serviertip, Suggestado, Erpresentado, also in wirklich verschiedenen Sprachen, in allen Sprachen der Welt steht Serviervorschlag. Und dann ist es so ein Bild drauf, so ein Glas Milch daneben. Joghurt, Joghurt. Aber was ist das Geheimnis in dem Serviervorschlag? Dass man nicht denkt, das Glas Joghurt wäre dabei oder so, damit die nicht verklagen können und sagen, ja, aber da ist ja ein Glas Joghurt abgegeltet. Wo ist das? Du bist bestimmt der einzige vegane in Ehrenfeld, oder? Weiß ich gar nicht. Hier gibt es auch so einen veganen Laden, der ist aber immer leer. Der vegane Burger-Laden. Aber bist du schon immer vegan oder erst der Kursche? Schon immer jetzt. Nee, jetzt halt dieses Jahr erst. Aber du hältst es durch, ne? Komplett. Oder hast du schon mal gesündigt und hast schon in eine Kuhuh gebissen oder so? Nee, ich darf auch gar nicht, ich weiß genau, ich bin so willenschwach, dass wenn ich einmal sündige, dann sofort alle dämme brechen und nicht so weit. Aber so ein leckeres Lachsfilet, ich habe mir gestern so Lachsburger geholt. So ein schöner Aal. So ein schöner eingelegter Aal. Uh, das ist schon lecker, das ist schon lecker. Geil. Zeitgleich. Und wir haben, glaube ich, so eine exakt gleiche Menge in dem. Nee, nee, nee, da war der Flo und den Gier. Wie paranoid seid ihr, aus fremden Flaschen zu trinken? Ich nehme keine Kaugummis von fremden Menschen an. Aber ansonsten alles. Ach so, du tauschst keine, du bist aber der einzige auf der Welt. Muss das jetzt hier sein, die Sauerei auf dem guten Holz? Ich darf mir, wenn ich mir angeboten wird, darf ich hier wohl noch verzehren. Ist das eine Orange oder eine Mandarine? Da ist eine Orange. Da sind es, wenn man nochitte, die du machen musst. Du brauchst ein Messer noch dabei, funktioniert das so gar nicht.
Mir ist es manchmal peinlich, wie egal es mir ist, aus fremden Flaschen zu trinken oder so.
Dann wischen die mir eine fremde Flasche und dann wischen die den Ding ab und nicht mehr so.
Das wäre mir auch scheissegal gewesen. Aber ich fühle mich dann immer so eklig.
Auch wenn jemand sagt, ich habe letztens die Fingernägel von mir und mir in der Badeweine gefunden.
Dann sind die mir so scheissegal.
Ich nehme auch mal benutze Kondom aus dem Mülleimer.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Klar, wenn die Seiken Das Wasser halten und das Wasser halten, was ist das Problem? Ich glaube, ich unterbreche das hier, meine Orangen. Aber hilft das denn, wenn man das sauber macht? Macht das aktiv irgendwie was besser? Also ich glaube, Aids kriegst du trotzdem. Ja, glaube ich auch. Nee, aber die Bakterien von so einem, bei mir, uns wurde früher gesagt, wir hatten so einen Dreckwegtag in der Schule, wo die Schüler genötigt werden. Da wurden alle der Schule, wo die Schüler genötigt wurden, Müll aufzuräumen. Wo ist denn der Jamal? Und bei den Kondomen, der ist weg, der kommt bald wieder. Und wir haben uns immer gesagt, dass auch wenn man in eine Spritze greift, ist es nicht so schlimm, weil wenn die irgendwie vier und zwei Stunden liegt, eine Heroinspritze, dann ist die nicht mehr gefährlich. Nicht mehr schlimm. Dann ist es es wie so eine gute Impfung. Antikörper, genau. Kam zu euch an die Schule auch der Aids-Bus? Bei uns kam der Aids-Bus kostenlos für alle. Kinder, heute ist der Aids-Bus da! Das war wie so eine Art Achterbahn. Der Bus war ein riesiges in so einem Kondom. Das war so eine Art wie war so eine Art, wie so eine Art Geisterbahn, in einem Bus, aber durch die man selber durchlaufen muss. Alles so gruselig und dann so Aids-Monster. Das kenne ich auch, aber was, gab es doch ein Maskottchen dazu? Aids-Spritze, ja, Spritzi. Wir hatten so eine, um mal den Körper zu erkunden, wurde bei uns so eine große, so eine Körperlandschaft aufgebaut und der Ausgang war der Darm. Ja, gibt den Düsseld bisschen auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, aber mega lehrreich. Aber wir haben gelernt über Aids, dass Aids potenziell über jede Körperflüssigkeit übertragen werden kann. Die Frage ist nur, wie viel. Welche Menge, ja. Ja, also gerade so Vaginalflüssigkeit und Sperma und Blut ist ganz schlimm, da reichen wenigste Mengen. Aber dann hatten die so eine Abstufung und ich glaube, das Schwächste ist Speichel und da muss man damit eine realistische, genau, wir hatten neun Liter und so wurde gesagt, neun Liter Speichel muss uns wissen, dass man eine realistische Chance hat, Aids zu bekommen und wir alle so eins, zwei, drei, passt, passt, passt, alles gut, passt schon, alles in Ordnung. Wir hatten Mitte der 90er kam bei uns der Bus, so ein Polizeibus war das? Nein, eine andere Geschichte.
Ein riesiger Bus in Form von einem riesigen Pikachu. Das war, wo Pokémon gelauncht wurde überall.
Da haben die überall. Das war wirklich eine Marketingaktion. Überall Comics hingelegt auf die Schuhe und so was. Und dann haben uns die Lehrer gesagt, nicht anfassen, weil die haben da irgendwelche Rauschgifte auf den Comics. Wir mussten die alle zurückgeben. Das ist ganz so eine Rauschgiftzeit, ne? Ganz komische Zeit, wo Rauschgift ein Thema war. Die ist bei mir gerade, die Rauschgiftzeit. Wie unglaublich spannend ist das für ein Kind zu haben, ein Comic hat Rauschgift an den Seiten. Ich habe auch beste Comic. Ist ein Comic, aber ist auch gefährlich. Habt ihr mal über siamesische Zwillinge nachgedacht? Nee. Ob das mal zu machen, die Operation? Der nächste Logischritt. Ja, das wäre, glaube ich, ganz geil. Es gibt ja in Amerika diese komischen Reportagen über ein Mädchen, die hat einfach... Die Schwester am Kopf, habe ich gesehen. Würdet ihr die grüssen auf der Strasse? So als Zwillinge würde man die grüssen? Ja, man hat so ein Zwillings-Zu. Sieht man jetzt nicht, aber die drei Finger gekreuzt, die andere dahinter und dann sagt man... Das sieht jetzt erst so eine Zwillingsbegrüßung. Geil. Aber ich merke schon, Zwillingsthemen nerven euch. Aber wer kontrolliert denn die Beine bei diesem Mädchen? Ich glaube, einer links, einer rechts. Überleg mal, die eine hat einen Freund. Nein, aber der kaufen wir auch währenddessen. Überleg doch mal realistisch jetzt mal. Wo wirklich sind sie am ehemessischen Zwillingspaar? Ich sehe immer nur diese Babys. Wenn man die nicht trennt, werden die auch erwachsen? Hallo, das hat man doch gerade erzählt. Das gibt es doch. Ja, klar. In Amerika ist es das. Die haben die anderen Charakter. Ja, das waren RTL die 25 schrägsten Menschen der Welt. Da waren die immer dabei. Immer dabei. Ach, da war schon ein Patron. Dann steht da Per Kussmark. Jürgen Milski, was ist das denn? Ja, zwei Köpfe. Er war nie auf. Er sie stoppelt. Dann hast du das letzte Mal das Wort schräg benutzt. Schräg. Klingt wie so eine Satt-Einschau, ne? Schräg aber lustig., jetzt bist du Jochen Schropp. Mit Luke Mockridge. Echt? Ja, so eine Impro-Show, wo die Bühne schräg steht. Nee, das war Jochen Schropp. Stimmt. Was ich mich frage, bei den chinesischen Zwillingen ist Mord. Wenn die einen Mord begeht, bei einerseits kannst du einfach sagen, die darf nicht ins Gefängnis, weil scheiß drauf, aber auf der anderen Seite kannst du nicht einfach eine unschuldige Person ins Gefängnis stehen. Das war richtig, zwei Versuche. Wenn die Möchenmord Was ist, wenn die eine die Todesstrafe bekommt? Ja, aber kommt doch an, wer bei diesen Schwestern aus Amerika, wer bedient denn die Hände und die Füsse? Was ist denn mit dieser ungenösen Schwester? Ich kenne das nicht. Worum geht's, ich bin nicht so auf das Bild.de. Also da ist eine ganz normale Frau, und dann hat die eine Schwester, eine Zwingenschwester, die kommt aus der Schulter raus. Nee, so funktioniert's nicht. Doch, ist aber so. Dass die eine Schwester nur der Kopf ist. Das sind zwei Frauen in einem Körper, dass es eine Person ist, plus Kopf. Fühlt die denn was? Fühlt die Finger? Oder hat die nur einen Kopf? Muss die auf Toilette? Ich verstehe. Hat die nur einen Kopf? Aber ja, es ist ja zwei Köpfe und zwei Arme, drei Füssen. Ich glaube, die steuern das halt gemeinsam. So linke Seite, rechte Seite. Da die Augen im Haus. Wie diese, bei Star Wars gibt es doch diese Raumflieger, wo es zwei Cockpils gibt. Ja, wie gesagt, so links rechts. Beide haben Lenkrad, wenn diese beiden nach außen, was passiert denn dann? Dann fliehen die so auseinander. Ja, wie bei den Simpsons, wo Maggie fährt, wo ich mir auch immer denke, wer lenkt das Auto? Maggie lenkt das Auto und es gibt einen Unfall? Ah, nee, Marge. Gott Gott sei Dank Matsch. Gibt es Vorteile über Zwillinge von Leuten, die keine Zwillinge sind? Nö. Ihr seid auch gut auseinander, ihr seid gut auseinanderzuhalten, finde ich. Was erzählt man sich auf den Strassen über Zwillinge? Ach gut, also viel Gutes eigentlich, ja. Aber es gibt immer mehr Zwillinge, finde ich, jeder auch im Prominentenbereich, Lisa und Lena, die Lochis, das stimmt, wir. Ich habe immer gesagt, wir wären die einzigen Prominenten aktuell, aber es gibt ja so viel mehr jetzt. Hältst du dich auch Ries? Die Maisenzwillinge? Wenn wir mal wären, aber sonst sind ja ganz viele Leute voraus. Meisen, die Maisenzwillinge, Ratiofarm-Zwillinge. Stimmt, Ratiofarm. Hat Ratiofarm mal arg angefragt bei euch? Ja. Nein, ernsthaft? Das dachte ich mir auch. Die lustige Geschichte, wir waren beim 99 Fire Film Awards, kennt ihr ja wahrscheinlich, auf der Berlinale, wo die richtig geilen Sachen ausgesagt werden. Und dann, das war gesponsert von Ratiofarm und die beiden beiden Zwillingen haben auch immer diesen Check dann übergeben. Wir stehen dann gerade um halb drei oder so im Gang, wollten nach draußen. Da kam das ganze besoffene Ratiofarben-Team, besteht aus zwei Mitte-40-jährigen Männern und einer Mitte-40-jährigen voluminösen Frau. Aber sehr gesund alle. Und hat gesagt, ja, Zwillingen, sieht aber super süss aus. Und dann, ja, da haben die gesagt, was sind die denn? Ja, von Ratiofarben und so, wir sollten uns bei denen melden und so was. Haben wir auch gemacht, es gab kein Feedback. Aber ihr kommt viel rum, ich habe euch mal auf dem Kölner Hauptbahnhof gesehen. Auf dem Hauptbahnhof drauf. Äh, obendrauf, wie ihr so ein Fan durch die Stadt geschwungen seid, ganz merkwürdig. Aber da war so eine Stand-up-Bühne aufgebaut, wo dann so Stand-up-Komödie war. Was denn? Wir haben aus dem Rebe-to-Go! Ja, am Hauptbahnhof, zwischen KFC und Rebe-to-Go! Wir kamen aus dem Rebe-to-Go und haben uns unser überteuertes Sandwich gekauft. Und dann sind wir da vorbeigeklendert. So Gouda mit Gurken drauf, mit Senfsoße. Und Spinat noch. Und so Spinatblätter, ja. Richtig gut. Und da war noch ein anderer prominenter, Kristall oder so, ne? Wann hast du da entdeckt? Schleppend. Und die Luke war schon damals die große Idee. Das ist der schlechteste Out-of-Stand-Up, so in der Durchgangs-Wunde so vorbeigeht. Aber ihr habt nicht selber performt. Nein, was soll ich denn erzählen? Ich dachte, ja, performt. Nee, nein. Findet ihr Kristall lustig? Ich höre nur Negatives über Kristall. Ja, in den Social-Media-Kanälen. Darf er das so? Nee, gar nicht. Ich kenne das nicht. Ich finde, dass sich langsam Luke Mockwitsch rausarbeitet aus der nervigen Schiene in die Entertainer-Richtung. Entertainer-Schiene, oder ist das... Aber wird er nicht einfach auf den nächsten Stefan Raab gedrillt? Ja, wird er auch. Das wird er definitiv. Im Interview ist die erste Frage, ob du der nächste Stefan Raab. Er sagt immer Nein, aber ich habe das Gefühl auch, dass sie ihn so langsam wollen in die Richtung schieben, einfach die akzeptieren das Nein nicht. Ich glaube, man braucht einfach kein Talent, man muss Talent nur oft genug behaupten, zu sagen, hier ist der neue, der neue a cool und irgendwann passt es schon so weil dann haben die leute sich auch an deinem stil gewohnt akka du hast keinen humor oder nein aber so ich glaube das ist auch ein selbstwerber so eine self-fulfing prophecy glaube ich habt ihr habt ihr angst nie aus eurer youtube-bubble rauszukommen so lange so gut bezahlt wird für jetzt ist mir das relativ scheißegal.
Nee, ähm, wieso, wir haben es ja eigentlich selbst in der Hand.
Wir können ja jetzt einfach weiter Gas geben. Ist es denn noch das Ziel, ins Fernsehen zu kommen, dass du um 23.15 Uhr auf Sat.1 kommst mit
Doppelt gemoppelt die Strassenfrage als du Wetterhau hast?
Was?
Das ist ziemlich genailed eigentlich, genau so heißt es nicht.
Das klang nach einem gut ausgearbeiteten Pitch. Ja. Doppelt gemoppelt. Wäre so ein geiler Titel für so eine Datingshow für Moppelt, doppelt gemoppelt. Oder für Zwillinge. Ja. Zwillingsdate. Nee, also die Frage, nee, ich habe da eigentlich keine Angst vor. Ich finde auch, dass YouTube sich im Bereich Entertainment auch langsam mausert. Also sachen wie ihr produziert sind ja auch tv reif quasi was ist denn noch so was gab es ja früher nicht für dich ist das ein gutes etikett ich gucke immer noch ich gucke trotzdem noch gut gemachte fernsehen gucke ich trotzdem noch gerne gut gemachtes fernsehen ja daneben ja das stimmt ja das stimmt tatsächlich dann halt so geile shows wie zum beispiel auch duell um die welt habe ich gern guckt kitchen impossible da sind gemachte Dinger, die pfeife ich mir, geh mal rein. Ich habe eine Homepage von dir gefunden, da ist ein ganz altes Bild und ich glaube, du weißt, wer ich will. Die ist gut versteckt, unter dem Titel Florentinwill.de. Ich dachte, das ist ein Gag, ist die Extrace gemacht worden in den letzten Jahren oder gab es sich damals? Nein, die Website hat mein Vater gemacht, als ich 16 war und hat mir dann gesagt, du hast jetzt eine eigene Website, cool, und dann dieses Bild für mich draufgetan, und wir haben irgendwie die Zugangsdaten verloren,
und konnten diese Website wieder...
Was ist denn da aufzufinden?
Wieder an, ihn anschreiben, lang rasieren!
Nein, wir können die Website wieder löschen, noch verändern, noch irgendwas, das einfach...
Ich dachte erst, das wäre so ein richtig geiler Gag,
die du jetzt hier quasi von einem halben Teil machen.
Ist es vielleicht auch, wir werden hier verarscht, glaube ich.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Die haben die Kontrolle verloren.
Wir haben komplett die Kontrolle verloren.
Man kann die Karriere von dir beenden, wenn man dieses Foto findet.
Kann man jetzt mal ein Teiliges Foto? Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich hier gute Internetverbindungen habe. Kann man gucken, wie viele Aufrufe die... Vor allem siehst du aus wie so ein typischer Kelly-Family-Fan, der auf dem Bus hinterherreist. So geht jetzt auch wieder auf Tour in Kelly-Family. Du siehst vor allem aus wie ein Essens-Fan. Ne, ich habe leider kein Internet, sorry. Tut mir leid, aber könnt ihr privat... Kannst du beschreiben, wie du aussiehst auf dem Foto? Ich sehe aus wie eine attraktive 19-jährige Gefangene im Körper eines 12-jährigen Jungs, der irgendwie ein bisschen zu lange im Keller gewohnt hat. Du bist eine Opernsängerin nach einer Geschlechtsumwandlung oder kurz davor. Ja, so ein bisschen. Unglaublich klären, dass es jetzt nicht so ist. Aber ich glaube, du hast ein gutes Bild jetzt davon, wie es ungefähr aussieht. Ich finde das klasse. Ich würde das auch einfach als Pressebild rausgeben. DVDL, das ist der neue Star. Er erzählt mit dem Willen. Das stimmt schon, ja. Das finde ich so schlecht, ja. Wir wurden von Thomas Gottschalk geblockt, habt ihr das mitbekommen. Echt? Ja. Block die Beste Guild, das ist der offizielle Hashtag. War das jetzt das grosse Comeback von Thomas Gottschalk? Also jahrelang nichts gehört, jetzt irgendwie die grosse Social Media Kedia-Kampagne, neue Sendung, mega gefloppt, schlechte Quote, war das? Aber die war auch verschnitten, ich glaube die Sendung hätte funktioniert, wenn die normal geschnitten gewesen wäre, das wäre so eine ganz normale... Wenn die nicht auf Sat.1 gelaufen wäre. Ja, wenn sie jemand gesehen hätte. Aber verschwindet jetzt wieder in der Versenkung und in zehn Jahren... Nee, der würde auch auf Po7 eine Sendung machen, der macht überall, der sammelt sich da... Ich finde den immer noch so gut als Moderator, ich gucke den gern. Ist er wirklich gut oder ist das halt einfach so Nostalgie? Ich glaube, er ist nicht gut gealtert, dieser Moderationsstil, aber ich finde das total geil. Ja, auch dieser Sexismus irgendwie, da war das wieder was lustig, jetzt ist er einfach nur so. Ja, auch diese ganze Kampagne auf Twitter, wo er dann diesen Twitter vorgenommen und seinen Kopf drauf gemacht hat, als Bild, da spricht er so viel irgendwie, was ist das Konzept davon?
Obwohl ich ja kein Fan davon bin, nur weil er ein paar Tage älter ist, zu sagen, der ist alt, wann setzt er sich zur Ruhe.
Ich meine, er ist Anfang 60, wenn er halt nur arbeiten will, soll er das halt machen.
Er ist halt sein Problem. Er ist dann auch bis 112 moderiert.
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Gut, bis zum Schluss.
Also, wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht hört er das ja hier.
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich werde immer darauf achten, dass der Benni dich in Ruhe lässt und zehn Meter Abstand hält und wenn du willst, dann muss er auch nicht im Studio sein, wenn du da bist. Ah, Benni hat's versaut, ne? Er hat's versaut. Ohne mich gäbe es aber auch keinen Kontakt. Ohne mich gäbe es noch nicht mal der Antwort. Das bringt ja nichts. Ja, aber eine Antwort im Gottschalk ist es mich schon. Benni sagt, er hat von Yoko gelernt. Immer penetrant sein, immer nachfragen und man soll sich nie schämen zu fragen. Das habe ich auch gesagt. Was hast du noch? Mach mal die Top-18-Dinge, die du von Joko gelernt hast.
Können wir auf Platz Nummer 18. Was hast du von Joko gelernt? Investition. Ja, Platz 18 immer nachfragen. Immer fragen, fragen. Das kannst du machen bei 90% der Leute, aber nicht bei Thomas Gottschalk. Dem kannst du nicht auf den Sack gehen. Der ist der Meister der Fragen. Was hast du noch von Joko gelernt? Ich hätte auch gelernt, dass man ich hole mal einen Schokobomb. Was habe ich noch gelernt? Nimm mal einen Schokobomb holen. Jede Sekunde spricht gegen dich. Aber ist Joko so ein bisschen euer Ziehvater, so ein bisschen euer Meister? Ja, aber wir haben uns ein bisschen aus den Augen verloren. Wie kam das eigentlich? Matthias uns aus den Augen verloren haben? Matthias Schweig war sich dazwischen. Ich glaube auch, weil er... Wie ist das zu Ende gegangen? Gab es einen Streit? Nee, im Gegenteil. Aber der Kontakt ist halt ein bisschen eingeschlafen. Und von deiner Seite kam es auch nicht so, der drang uns mal wieder zu kontaktieren. Ja, Fernbeziehungen. Das Problem war Fernbeziehungen. Aber bis dahin war er auf der Joko Winterscheid Masterclass., so ein bisschen Würgereiz-Training, jeden Morgen uiih!
Und die Lachtraining, ja!
Ja, aber über Joko kann ich das Wort verlieren, das ist ein richtig freies Jahr.
Ich möchte die Frage nochmal stellen, weil es mich persönlich interessiert.
Wenn du jetzt den Frank Elstens anrufen würdest, was macht der denn gerade, ist der gerade aktiv?
Und wie geht der ans Telefon?
Der ist glaube ich auf Mallorca einfach so in seiner...
Mallorca?
Ja, der ist so unterwegs und der erlebt da Abenteuer. Also der erlebt wirklich einfach Abenteuer. Du könntest wirklich so eine Zeichentrickssehende machen. Was für ein Abenteuer? Der hat irgendwann mal erzählt. Wie Timon Strupp, so eine Jungfrau gerettet von einem Drachen. Ja, nee, aber der hat so, soll ich das jetzt? Banzi-Sprungen. Der war ich mit meinem Schiff unterwegs und es war so ein ganz altes Schiff, irgendwie so ganz und es war komplett erneuert, so mit neuem Holzboden und dann waren wir da mitten auf der See und dann ist der Motor, weil der so schwer war, ist durch den Boden des Schiffs durchgebrochen und war weg. Das war so ein altes Schiff, aus ganz Holz und lackiert und so ganz edel und da haben die so einen krassen Motor, so 5 PS Motor.
Ist das schleichend weggesackt? Nee, ich glaube, also du sitzt da irgendwie so.
Und dann war ein Loch im Boot.
Einfach ein Loch im Boot. Einfach Loch im Boot, der Motor ist weg. Zu schwer. Das zentrale Stück des Schiffs und dann, ja, was jetzt? Die Masse von so einer sterbenden Sonne und der zieht sich jetzt langsam in den Erdkerl. Ja, genau, da mussten die halt da Notwassern und sind dann irgendwie da zurückschwommen. Oder haben dann irgendwie, also solche Sachen erlebt er halt einfach so. Krass. Der macht abenteuer so der hat auch so ein kilo handel macht die morgen so ja genau er joggt auch mit zu handeln und er hat auch viele projekte der hatte auch irgendwie der hat der hat ja ganz viele nobelpreisträger interviewt der hat dich geformt unter anderem ja und er hat ganz viele nobelpreisträger interviewt irgendwie schon vor jahren irgendwie bevor die gestorben sind und so und versucht das irgendwie unterzubzubringen. Hat der nicht noch eine Sendung, welche Menschen ... Nee, die Menschen der Woche gibt es nicht mehr. Sehe ich, gucke ich doch jetzt wocheinander immer. Ja, Wiederholung, oder? Der Gottschall war doch schon bei dem, oder? Ja, war schon zwei Jahre her. Was hast du denn für Tipps von Frank Elster mitgenommen? Ganz wichtig, beim Moderieren kann ich immer wieder sagen. Genau, gib mal ein paar Tipps mit. Moderieren, ganz, ganz, das ist glaube ich der, einer der ersten Tipps, er war in so einem Einzeltraining mit Frank Elster, war in seinem Büro und hat gesagt, hat der Händenknopf auf und dann hat der so gemacht, ne? Ja, natürlich, genau, und dann hat er sich zurückgelehnt und dann so, ja, jetzt moderieren Sie mal, und dann gibt er dir irgendwie einen Text mit irgendeinem Lokalartikel und dann moderierst du halt den Artikel an, als wärst du in so einer Lokalsendung. Dann sagt er, Florian, erst mal, das allerwichtigste ist, du musst das Auge schmeicheln. Das heißt, das Auge. Du musst das Auge schmeicheln, das heißt, deine Körperform darf nichts Eckiges haben, weil das stößt den Zuschauer ab. Und du nimmst den Hut mit dem Stern. Deswegen gucke ich nicht deine Laminate. Dann siehst du borstig aus. Und deswegen, wenn du moderierst, also wenn jetzt euch so die klassische Angela Merkel-Handhaltung vorstellt, dann hast du in deiner Silhouette, hast du so Ecken, deine Ellenbogen sind so Ecken in der Silhouette. Deswegen eher so auf Schritthöhe die Hände, dass du wirklich so eine gleitende Form. Und das ist der erste Tipp, den Frank Elstner und du denkst dir, okay. Ich habe alles gelernt. Welchen Tipp hast du noch bekommen? Was ist noch ein heisser Tipp von Frank Elstner? Heisser Tipp ist immer, den Zuschauer irgendwie über die Sendung hinweg an die Hand nehmen, im Sinne davon, dass am Ende irgendwas geschafft ist. Also zum Beispiel, ich hatte so ein eigenes Video gemacht über Chemtrails. Da ging es um Chemtrails, um diese Verschwörungstheorie und hat gesagt, Flurruntin, machen Sie doch folgendes, nehmen Sie sich ein Modellflugzeug und während Sie moderieren, während den zehn Minuten des Videos, bauen Sie Stück für Stück dieses Modellflugzeug zusammen. Nach jedem Abschnitt nehmen Sie einen Teil und fügen es an dieses Modellflugzeug, so dass am Ende des Videos das ganze Flugzeug da ist. Aber das soll jetzt nur 1,30 lang sein. Und der Zuschauer sieht, ah, da wurde was geschafft. Hast du das schon mal? Und da denken sie dann auch so, das ist so gut. Das sind 1.800 Teile und das Video wird so zwei Stunden. Aber es gab einen extrem lustigen Moment. Und da hat er irgendwas moderiert, was nicht übertragen wurde, sondern irgendwie so eineleihung. Ich glaube bei Axel Springer das goldene Lenkrad von Auto, Motor, Bild, Sport gedönst. Und dann hat er moderiert und dann waren auch zwei Laudatorinnen da. Und es waren die beiden Gewinner von Germany's Next Topmodel, der ersten und der zweiten Staffel. In der zweiten Staffel war ja diese Sarah Nuru. Die erste war noch Lena Gerken. Genau, die die Schwarze war, hat beim zweiten Mal gewonnen.
Und das war so, dann stand er in der Mitte und hat moderiert und links und rechts von ihm standen diese beiden Frauen.
Und ich glaube, das Rechte ist sein falsches Auge.
Und auf der rechten Seite stand halt die die die Sarah nur die Schwarze.
Und dann hat er erst was gesagt und dann hat die die Lena Gerke was gesagt.
Und als die Sarah angefangen hat, hat er sich brutal erschrocken, weil er nicht gesehen hat, weil er nicht wusste, dass noch jemand neben ihm steht. Aber als Außenstehender sah es so lustig aus, so der weisse man redet, die weisse Frau und die schwarze Frau und die so boah, hohohoho, wenn der Rassismus so durchbricht. Als wäre da gerade so eine Wespe auf ihn eingeflohen, so boah, einfach so, aber er hat sie einfach nicht gesehen und das war so schön, man hat so mitleidend Zuschauer ist es nicht aufgefallen, weil er hat keine Kanten gehabt. Richtig, genau, die Zuschauer konnten ihn kaum unterscheiden vom Szenenbild, weil er war so sanft. Er hatte keine Kanten. Ja, also das war schon verrückt. Aber obwohl Lena Gerke ist, sie aber schlagt den Star jetzt Lena Gerke gegen Lena Meyer-Landrut. Das ist ja schon ein Kampf der Lena. Welcher Hand ich meine Limo halten soll, dann gibt es ja auch so schön, ja. Oh ja, aber ich bin für Lina. Ich bin ein sehr großer Lena-Mailerland-Roth-Fan. Ich auch, ich auch. Habt ihr dich schon mal live gesehen? Die geilste Frau der ganzen Welt. Ja, die hat wohl jeder, oder? Ja, ich glaube auch. Ja gut, aber das ist ja noch ganz anders aus. Nee, live war die, war doch nie im Neo-Magazin oder so. Warum auch immer. Aber ihr habt doch auch Leute, über die ihr euch lustig macht, die dann auch dann irgendwie dann auch nie antworten, oder Lena muss doch eigentlich mittlerweile, wenn ihr sie fragt, die kommt doch, oder kommt sie einfach nicht aus Prinzip. Bei uns ist man mit Dead Adam, ist das gleiche. Die wollen nicht so, die haben Zeit und so, aber wir haben uns früher mal...
Wir haben dir Zeit, ja wir haben eine riesige Zeit, nur drei Wochen haben die Wollen nicht, die lügen uns an, das riecht ich auch, die lügen uns an, wir haben keine Zeit, ich sehe einen Tourplan, ich sehe, ich weiß, wo ihr wohnt, ihr seid den ganzen anderen zuhause und kifft, die haben Zeit, aber wir haben keine Zeit. Die haben Zeit, die kommen nicht. Ach verdammt, scheiße. Wir müssen erst einen Namen machen, Dennis. Ihr seid ja die Zuschauer, die wir auch erreichen wollen. Ja. Was haben wir bei euch für ein Standing, für einen Namen, sind wir die Ulk-Youtuber-Nudeln? Also ihr seid die YouTube-Ulk-Buben. Das ist doch auch wieder scheiße. Ja, nee, aber ihr seid schon die ernst nehmen. Also ihr seid die, auf die, also wenn ich nicht weiß, wie ich einen YouTuber finden soll, gucke ich euch, um zu wissen, wie man den einschätzen soll. Weil ihr seid so mein moralischer Kompass auf YouTube. Okay, gut. Was ich immer so sage, ihr seid so die einzigen YouTuber, die man sich anschauen kann. Das hast du uns auf einer Party vor zwei Jahren gesagt. Das ist sehr betrunken. Aber ihr seid halt immer noch YouTuber. So. Ja. Also ihr seid Teil davon, aber zumindest die, die ein bisschen was richtig machen. Benni und Dennis, vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart. Ganz kurz, eure Schama-Frisuren, eure Intimrisuren, Frisuren. Leicht getrimmt, aber natürlich. Ziegenbart. Leicht getrimmt, aber natürlich. Am Wochenende aalglatt. Alles klar, vielen Dank dafür, macht's gut, danke, dass du da war. Ciao. Mensch, die beiden. Das sind schon echt irre Füchse, die da in ihrem YouTube-Kosmos machen, was sie wollen. Und das finde ich so gut. Das finde ich auch klasse, dass sie einfach nichts aufakturieren lassen. Weißt du, es gibt ja viele verschiedene Menschen auf dieser Welt. Und es gibt erfolgreiche und nicht erfolgreiche. Und was ich so gut finde, ist, dass manchmal die nicht erfolgreichen auch, wir haben beide hier heute, ja, wir haben eine bunte Mischung, wir haben die erfolgreichsten Podcaster und Podcaster, die gerade noch am Anfang stehen, aber wir bringen sie alle zusammen hier beim Podcast UFO, vielleicht haben uns die alle noch mittlerweile schon überholt, wir haben sie da tatsächlich, es ist gelungen, alte Freunde, Bekannte auch zu sammeln. Super. Also generell neue Projekte zu empfehlen, wir sind ja auch nicht das, wie viele sagen, das abgehobene UFO. Ja, Arroganz-Ufo werden wir geschimpft. Ja, Arroganz-Ufo, Comedy-Diktatur, Idioten-Ufo, ja, Hilfe, Hilfe, ich ertrinke! All das, aber wir sagen... Nein, wir können auch mal nach unten gucken. Und auch die von ganz unten zu uns nach ganz oben holen. Ja, wir werfen auch mal gerne so Rettungsringe der Comedy-Kunst. Auch zehn Stock Werke in die Tiefe, denn hier sind sie vom Gag Reflex Podcast Lars und Andreas Paulsen! Ich wollte gerade das lebende Rätsel euch sagen, und zwar ist es wie folgt. Das ist einmal so, dass ich für euch eine Menge Leute habe. Ich habe uns einen Tee aufgesetzt. Danke. Oder einen Tee. Aber war gut, oder? Krass, ich sehe die Welt mit anderen Augen jetzt. Das ist total abgefahren. Mensch, so ein bisschen Podcast-Clash, der Gag-Reflex ist ja der richtig erfolgreich. Stimmt ja. Was hast du denn so aggressiv gesagt gerade? Ich weiß ja nicht, keine Ahnung, aber es ist ja auch ein guter Podcast, das kann man auch mal empfehlen. Gag-Reflex ist cool. Auf Soundcloud. Kann man gut machen. Der macht das doch groß genug, können alle satt werden. Du hast doch selbst, wie viel Geld man mit Podcasts machen kann. Patron ist nicht beschränkt. Patron nimmt alle auf. Ihr wollt euch einladen, heute ist die 50. Folge das Podcast-Ufo. Die 50. Folge. Und dafür haben wir euch eingeladen. Lars Greg Paulsen von Rocket Beans und Andreas Link von Rocket Beans. Auch von Rocket Beans, genau. Hallo, weil ihr gerade in Köln seid. Genau, für die, die es nicht wissen, ich habe eine Late-Night-Show bei Rocket Beans, die Lars moderiert. Schön, dass wir hier sein dürfen. Das ist ja echt klasse, dass das mal geklappt hat. Letztes Mal wollen wir das auch machen, aber in Hamburg ist halt immer keine Zeit. Oh, das ist ein bisschen stresslos. Die macht das Moin Moin, die Hamburg-Ticken, die wunderbar. Ja, du musst irgendwie als Werwolf dich verkleiden und so, da hat man einfach keine Zeit mehr. Da hast du halt vier Stunden Let's Play im Keller und kannst nichts aufnehmen. Ja, ja, ja. Das ist halt immer so. Das ist ein hartes, hartes Buss für Broadcaster. Ist ein richtig hartes Buss. Es war ja erst Eddie, weil DVDL hat ein bisschen was gedroppt, irgendwie so ein paar die Insider-Infos rausgehauen. Wann? Zu was? Zu Rocket Beans hat gesagt, Authentizität ist wichtig und ich dachte, er hat das alles gelesen, ich dachte, er kriegt so mit, was er Chef so sagt in Medien. Guckst du mich so an bei Chef? Ich dachte, wir dürfen nicht mit den Medien sprechen. Die TV-Medien interessiert euch gar nicht mehr.
Ja, ne, was, Chefs, das ist dir klar, wir können nicht alles lesen, was die irgendwo absondern.
Ich lese nur noch den Beansletter, das ist so interne Zeitschrift, wo manchmal so lustige Gewinnspiele veranstaltet werden.
Im Rocket Beans Forum hat sich jemals jemand bis jetzt als ich ausgegeben, und dann habe ich das Voting gesagt und der hat den löschen lassen.
Der hat den einfach so mit so einem Schnipser, okay, gut, In meinem Kopf hat er so eine Macht und hat einfach auf den gezeigt und er löst sich so Flammen auf. So ein armer Mensch, der da irgendwie jetzt ich wollte nur damit sagen, dass ich es nicht cool finde und man vielleicht ihn bitten könnte, einen anderen Namen zu nehmen oder so. Und du hast ihn einfach zerstört jetzt. Du hast eine Existenz zerstört im Internet. Im Forum oder? Im Forum, ja.
Habt ihr auch ein Forum eigentlich?
Gute Arbeit Originals? Ne, Quatsch.
Podcast-UFO? Pufopedia.
Das kenne ich natürlich. Stimmt. Oh, da habe ich neulich drin gelesen, weil ich irgendwie, wie
immer, jeden Sonntagabend gucke ich mich mal selbst
und gucke, wie viele Aufrufe, Suchergebnisse es gibt.
Du hast einen Aufruf, ne, bestimmt. Da gibt es einen
Eintrag in diesem
Pufopedia, wo steht, sinnss, Andreas Links spielt keine Rolle im Podcast-Universum und dann, auch für den Rest der Menschheit spielt er keine Rolle. Ich dachte, okay, die haben mich als Persönlichkeit komplett erfasst. Wie hast du vor, das zu ändern? Was ist der große Plan? Soll man das wirklich ändern? Weißt du nicht, dass im Bohnen-Wiki, also in unserem Rocket Beans-Wiki auch, wiki auch ich glaube es steht immer noch drin als trivia unter deinem eintrag steht verbindet eine hassliebe mit andreas lynch ich weiß nie wo das hergekommen ist aber auf den hass den grund durch die jassen ich weiß es nicht weiß nicht viel konkurrenz da ist schon ein paar sachen vorgefallen ja da wollen wir jetzt nicht konkurrenzsituation klar für mich ist die Die Vanessa-Geschichte. Ja, ja, aber Pufupedia ist für mich auch das neue Reddit. Das stimmt. Es war mal eine der grössten Websites im Internet, weil die von Bots überrannt wurde. Ich glaube, es war eine der grössten, gefülltesten und mit dem meisten Wissen auf einer Seite jemals eine Website. Aber jetzt ist alles gelöscht worden. Aber funktioniert wieder für uns wie geht's euch alles acht stunden fahrt hier für zehn minuten show aber okay das ist schon immer abgefahren das finde ich auch krass so wenn man irgendwo auch wenn irgendwo eingeflogen wird wo man denkt okay so ein riesiger stahlvogel irgendwie wo die menschheit tausende jahre daran experimentiert hat nur damit du irgendwie sagen kannst und dann fährst du wieder nach Hause. Das ist schon strange. Sind Flugzeuge aus Stahl gebaut? Aus Aluminium und können keinen Stahl schmelzen. Ja, aber man hat es gern wissen, ob das aus Stahl ist, ich wusste es nicht, das war eine reine Interessefrage. Und warum, wenn die auch aus Stahl sind, genau wie die Stahlträger vom 9-11 World Trade Center, warum können die dann einfach nicht mehr machen? Gerade weil sie kein Stahl sind, ist es eine Frage. Also würdest du sagen, ist das wirklich passiert oder was, 9-11? Das ist dann dann auch geklaut, dieser Diebstahl, der dann da verwendet wird für diese Flugzeuge. Ermittelt man? Was? Ich habe die Gag-Ebene, ich habe die Mitte-Ebene nicht geraten. Diebstahl-Stahl. Ach Gott, Andreas Linkstein. Mit deinen ratenscharfen Wortwissen, ey, der muss ja erstmal dahinter kommen.
Nee, uns geht's gut, um die Frage zu beantworten. Ich hab das auch bei Werwolf gehabt, weil du einfach, man fährt ewig dahin, ewig dahin, hat man das Gefühl, man muss jetzt deliveren, ist Werwolf in der ersten Runde, kann also nicht sagen, bei der Runde ist man sofort tot, fährt nach Hause. Da habe ich Sechsterpack geguckt, das ist eigentlich im Hotelzimmer.
Da sah ich dann so, ist das der traurigste Abend, den ich jemals hatte. Da warst du abends dann so halb neugend auf dem Hotelzimmer und dann so, das ist mein Leben, so einfach so eine Bierdose, Bauchnabel abgestellt, im Sechserpack im Fernsehen, alles klar. Plötzlich wird dann bewusst, die Minibar wird gar nicht gezahlt, vor allem. Okay, fuck, ich habe mehr Geld verloren, als ich es bekommen habe. Aber hat sich ein bisschen inspirieren lassen da von von Sechserpack oder so? Wären deine Sketche jetzt auch immer mehr in Richtung Sechserpack oder? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Die haben natürlich auch die Masse begeistert. Ja, die Messlatte immer noch für Sketchcomedy in Deutschland, finde ich. Tatsächlich, als wir die Marktforschung bekommen haben, wurden wir verglichen mit Knallerfrauen und Sechserpack. Wirklich? Ja, echt. Und ich glaube, es wurde kritisiert, dass wir weniger so sind wie die. Also wahrscheinlich, der Weg sollte langsam einfach in die Richtung führen. Das ist halt alles, was Deutschland an Comedy kennt. Top notch. Warum seid ihr denn nicht die dreistend drei, das würde nur wirklich passen, auch in welcher Besetzung auch immer. Ja, stimmt. Du bist nicht so dreist, Bluantin. Ich bin überhaupt nicht dreist, ich bin eher frech. Das ist mir schon aufgefallen, dass du frech bist. Gut, dass du es mal sagst. Ja, ich bin ein bisschen frech, aber ich bin überhaupt nicht dreist, interessanterweise, aber mega frech. Frech, ne? Ich glaube, bei niemandem, der jemals hat gesagt, ich bin frech, ist das zu. Niemand, der wirklich frech, der mich sagen würde, oh, ist ein frecher Kerl, würde ich das von sich behaupten. Ja, oder ist das, ich bin ein bisschen verrückt. Aber ich habe einen richtig schwarzen Humor. No, du hast gar keinen Humor. Du hast gar keinen Humor. Egal, was du über deinen eigenen Humor hast, sagst du, du hast keinen Humor. Das stimmt, diese typischen Twitter-Biografien, wo man direkt man direkt weiß, ich bin Querdenker. Nope, bist du nicht, einfach gar nicht. Null. Stimmt. Aber was ich nochmal zu diesem Anreise-Ding sagen wollte, ich frage mich immer, wann man den Moment verpasst oder warum man den Moment verpasst, weil anfangs, wenn man das vorgeschlagen bekommt von irgendeiner Firma, bei euch war es jetzt auch so, heißt das manchmal, ja, ihr könnt ja irgendwie mit dem Flugzeug oder mit dem Zug oder so, können wir ja mal gucken. Und eigentlich müsste man dann von Anfang an sagen, ja, Flugzeug, auf jeden Fall Flugzeug. Aber irgendwie drückt man dann so ein bisschen rum und lässt es so schweifen, dann ist ein Tag vorher und dann sind deine Zugtickets gebucht. Und dann ist der Flixbus. Genau, dann sind wir hier mit dem Lkw hier angekommen. Wie gelines Fahrrad einfach. Also ich glaube, je erfolgreicher man wird, desto arroganter muss man glaube ich auch sein, weil man dann einfach nicht mehr... Wie erfolgreich bist du gerade auf einer Skala von eins bis zehn? Von eins bis zehn bin ich jetzt knapp vor der zehn tatsächlich. Ja, wirklich? Also viel ist nicht mehr da rum. Nee, ich bin ein Weltstar. Wir hätten dich aber auch fast ausgeladen, weil die Rückfrage nicht kam, ob du nicht vielleicht in ein Flugzeug kommen könntest. Er will freiwillig mit dem Zug fahren, ist er wirklich so ein Star, brauchen wir den hier wirklich? Wer wäre denn stattdessen gekommen dann? Noch mal Andreas. Zweimal, nacheinander. Wir haben eine sehr gute Postproduktion. Wir haben da viele Machen. Wir waren nicht mit dem Finger von Varoufakis, ich weiß nicht. Da kriegt man so einen ganzen Andreasa locker dahin. Wenn so ein kleiner Mittelfinger wäre, ist das finde ich ja auch nicht. Da bist du auch nicht mehr weit entfernt. Ein paar Barthaare noch dran, da haben wir es im Prinzip. Aber es ist halt witzig, weil bei Rocket Beans ist die Anreise immer zehn Minuten, man hat dann acht Stunden Live-Steige zu füllen. Null Material, ich bin genau das Gegenteil von einem anderen. Das ist die Frage, was besser ist, ja. Beißt du ja. Aber das ist auch der kürzeste Podcast aller Zeiten, so ein bisschen, wenn wir irgendwie 15 Minuten schnacken, aber hat nicht immer irgendwie, wer war das, Bastian Pastewka oder so beim Comedypreis gesagt, ja, wie lange geht so ein Podcast, fünf Minuten, ja die Zeit, als du gefragt hast. Das kann sein. Wir haben ihn eingeladen, er hat zugesagt und wir haben das noch nie eingelöst. Wir haben vor allem auch eine Zusage bekommen von Johann Kühl. Ich glaube, der war das auch mit der Schriftung. Genau, Johann Kühl. Stimmt, der hat mir doch noch ein Bier ausgegeben. Aber der meinte, er kann nicht so lange, also auch körperlich. Er hat gesagt, er kann nicht so lange reden. Ja, also fünf Minuten. Ja, aber der Mann ist Stand-Up-Comedian, wie kann ich reden? Er hat gesagt, ich kann nicht so lange reden, ich weiß nicht, ob ich so lange reden kann. Da dachte ich mir, ist das ein Brilliant-Scherz? Aber er hat nicht dieses Gesicht, dieses typische Johann König, ich mache ein Deckgesicht gemacht. Also habe ich gefragt, aber ist das nicht ihr Job? Da bin ich ganz ehrlich gesagt, ja, eigentlich schon, stimmt. Hast du ihn gleich konfrontiert? Ja, vielleicht sollte ich es doch hinkriegen, hat er dann gesagt. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, wir laden ihn immer ein. So war frech von dir in so zu. Ja. Ja, oder bin so ein bisschen frech, ein Frechdachs. Ein bisschen Querdenker. Aber vor allem dann, ich habe jetzt so ein Interview gesehen mit Synchronsprechern, mit den berühmtesten Synchronsprechern Deutschlands und da wurde auch die Frage gestellt, so, was machen Sie, um Ihre Stimme gesund zu halten? Und einer hat gesagt, so, ja, ich versuche mindestens einmal am Tag zu sprechen. Ja, okay, also, okay. Was führt das für ein Leben, dass er das versuchen muss? Ja, also wirklich einfach ganz normal sprechen mit Leuten. Also okay, gut, das ist das grosse Geheimnis. Ich frage mich immer, sind das Brilliant Minds, die Hammer Gags raushauen? Oder manchmal sind Leute, die ernst antworten, die lustigeren Menschen. Das kann sein, ja. Aber sagen wir mal ehrlich, wenn man als Single jetzt irgendwie mal eine Woche Urlaub hat, was wird denn da gross geredet? Da bist du nur nur im Bett, zockst irgendwie, dann sagst du vielleicht mal, oh, schreit mal ins Teamspeak. Pass doch jetzt mal an. Mindestens einmal am Tag sagen reicht nicht. Das bewusst nicht. Richtig mit euch selber? Ja, ich auch. Ich höre das ja immer bei dir. Bei dir habe ich es tatsächlich gehört, ja. Aber fühlt ihr euch dann schlecht auch gleichzeitig, wenn ihr euch dabei erwischt? Ich finde es gesund. Ich finde es ganz gesund. Weil ich habe das früher immer so bei meiner Oma mitbekommen, dass sie das halt gemacht hat und fand das schon immer ein bisschen strange. Und jetzt, wenn ich das selbst mache, denke ich so, oh, du wirst jetzt langsam schon zu deiner Oma. Früher oder später wird ja jeder zu seiner Oma. Da muss man ja irgendwann ins Gesicht blicken. Ja, stimmt. Aber ich kenne sie ja gut. Aber ich finde, wir sollten ein bisschen Werbung für einen Podcast machen. Gaggabflex ist wirklich ein ganz tolles Produkt. Auch so von oben herab werben. Nein, ich meine, es ist ein ganz tolles Produkt, was nach dieser ganzen, ich nenne es mal Podcast-Ufo-Welle gekommen ist. Dieser ganzen Podcast, wo man, wo es Leute meint, oh, das klingt aber einfach, was sie beiden da machen, die ganzen Gags, die um sich herum hauen,
klar, und dann kamen so Leute
wie Vivian Böhmermann und Olli Schulz, die
nachmachen zu müssen und ihr natürlich auch.
Aber das finde ich ganz toll, wirklich, ironiefrei.
Wir hatten uns halt überlegt, sollen wir jetzt eben auch
genau so anfangen, einfach zu zweit zu schnacken
und über irgendwelche Themen zu reden und Scherze
zu machen und irgendwie hatten wir da beide nicht so
groß Bock drauf und dann haben wir eben
dieses Konzept von Jack in the Mir mehr oder weniger eins zu eins geklaut. Haben wir auch offensiv am Anfang auch gesagt. Offensiv haben wir ein Google-Bild von mir genommen, das einfach mit der Google-Bildersucher. Und dann kam halt sofort an mir. Auf jeden Fall. Ihr habt auch echt ein bisschen was davon. Also komplett. Ja, und seitdem sind wir da am Gängen sozusagen. Aber habt ihr das Gefühl, dass ihr seitdem ihr den Podcast macht, besser Ratschläge geben könnt, also dass man zu euch kommen kann und euch noch um Rat fragen kann? Vor allem habe ich das Gefühl, ich müsste jedem helfen, wenn ich auf der Straße jemanden sehe, der ein bisschen traurig aussieht, dann sage ich mal, schick uns doch mal deine Frage und dann beantworten die. Ja, das war ich. Ihr kriegt ja manchmal Rückmeldungen, so von wegen, ah, ihr habt mir wirklich geholfen. Ja, tatsächlich, ja. Kass. Kam schon vor, ja, wobei wir ja von Anfang an sagen, wir helfen nicht wirklich, wir helfen da, wo wir nicht können und so weiter. Aber es gibt schon Leute, die sagen danach, hey, danke und so, es klingt zwar strange, aber ihr habt wirklich mir weiterhelfen können. Ich hätte tatsächlich Schluss machen sollen. Jetzt haben wir Schluss gemacht, jetzt geht es mir gut. Witzigerweise, ein Mädel, dem haben wir geraten, oder der haben wir geraten, irgendwie, ja, lass mich. Genau, sie hat es gemacht, das war nochmal geschwürdig. Clever. Mir geht es hier wirklich besser. Da haben wir gesagt, ey, lass dich bloß nicht wieder auf deinen Ex ein, no way, das klappt nicht nochmal, wenn es einmal Schluss war. Und dann schrieb sie so zwei Tage später, ja danke nochmal, bin jetzt wieder, versuch es nochmal mit meinem Ex. Aber trotzdem danke, sagt es ihr. Trotzdem eine Freundschaftsanfrage bei Facebook geschickt. Natürlich. Tonnes Gespräch. Hast du Podcaster-Vorbilder? Ähm, natürlich. Also speziell, wenn ich so nach Amerika schaue, habe ich natürlich Down Under habe ich natürlich auch Podcasts, die ich super finde. Ich sag nur mal, sowas wie zum Beispiel Mark Merrill hat einen natürlich nachträglich beeindruckt, aber auch Pete Holmes, toller Podcast, Comedy Bang Bang. Absolute Nummer eins der Podcast-Vorbilder. Jetzt gerade ist es Improv for Humans. Doch, Improv for Humans, und da habe ich auch viele gerne so Drehbuchautoren-Podcasts, Writers Panel, Panels Panel, Writers Writers Writers Panel Riders, Writers on the Storm und so weiter. Es sind alles gute Podcasts. Mein Podcaster-Vorbild ist ja Stefan Dietze, natürlich, ist ja klar, einmal so tolle Gäste wie er empfangen und natürlich auch die tollen Jungs von Radio Nucular, die es immer wieder schaffen, fantastische Blog-Best. Also nennst du ein bisschen die, die Podcasts gross gemacht haben, die durch ihre Live-Touren, durch ihren Merch auch eine unglaubliche Geldmenge angehäuft haben. Auch für uns durchaus Vorbilder, was ist mal in Richtung, ich weiß nicht, bis Folge 100 werden wir schon ein paar Live-Auftritte gemacht haben. Ja, oder Geld. Und das unter Geld gemacht haben. Ich denke, das sind auf jeden Fall unsere Vorbilder, was das angeht. Auf jeden Fall. Und wir hatten die Gelegenheit, Ihnen ein paar private Fragen zu stellen.
Und wie das sich angehört hat, das hört ihr gleich nach einer kurzen Werbung. Bis gleich.
Milch!
Hallo und herzlich willkommen vom Radio Nukular Podcast.
Dominik Hammers und Rockstar Nachtsheim.
Max, Rockstar, genannt Nachtsheim.
Ich habe gerade gemerkt, ich liebe es, Dinge aufzuladen.
So mein Handy aufzuladen, das ist so ein richtig befriedigendes Gefühl.
Ich dachte, die Stimmung...
Nee, wenn irgendwas macht...
Was ist es, wenn du es am Sonntag Mittag im Bett?
Mehr Verstecken muss ich neben dir?
Noch mal so zwei USB-Codes, bis die jetzt geht. Ja. Und dann alles aufgaben. Switch, iPad, iPhone, iPod, alles was... Geil. Ich habe heute in der Bahn gesessen mit meinem Anker, USB-Netzteil mit vier Ports, Uhr, Handy, um ein externer Arm. Ich mag es total gerne, wenn irgendwelche Prozesse im Hintergrund laufen. Wenn irgendwie die Waschmaschine läuft, wenn die Waschmaschine läuft und ich währenddessen irgendwie masturbiere, weiß ich, da passiert was, das ist irgendwie gut genug zur Zeit, und wenn gleichzeitig mein Handy geladen wird, die Waschmaschine läuft, die meine Bettdecke trocknet, klar, meine Bettdecke trocknet und alles gleichzeitig läuft, wenn ich mir wow, unfassbar, und gleichzeitig noch irgendwas hochlädt, das ist für mich wirklich das Beste. Neulich, wo wir gerade bei Aufladen waren, neulich bin ich mit nach Hamburg gefahren und dann sass neben mir eine Frau, die auch nach Hamburg gefahren ist, in so einem großen Vierer.
Das ist ein Zufall.
Und die war, und es ist manerweise immer so ein bisschen unangenehm, mit Fremden da abzuhängen und so, und die wollte auch immer das Gespräch suchen, das ist immer so ein bisschen unangenehm, weil auch die Fronten nicht so ganz geklärt sind, so wem gehört die Steckdose, wem gehört die Armlehne und so, das war alles so ein bisschengeklärt, aber sie hat diesen tollen Satz gesagt, wir haben nur eine Steckdose, du kriegst bis Bremen und ich krieg ab Bremen. Und ich so, okay, mega geil, weil man kriegt so selten so klare Ansagen von Fremden. Das ist mir mal aufgefallen, ich wusste das so zu schätzen, ich krieg die Steckdose bis Bremen und alles war klar. Ich konnte meine Tat, meine Fahrt klar. Ich hatte letztens einen Platz reserviert und mein Platz war reserviert und die Diagonal da gegenüber in so einer Vierreihe hatte eine Frau, so eine ganz unangenehme alte Ekelfrau, die sich ständig auch beschwert zu allem und die hatte ihre Füsse diagonal auf meinen Sitz gelegt, aber so ganz an den Rand. Und dann habe ich mich da hingesetzt so vorsichtig und habe mich so in Zeitlupe bewegt so, okay, jetzt nimm's weg, nimm's weg und sie hat's nicht weggenommen. Du willst ja nicht direkt was sagen, deswegen machst du erst so körperlich so.
Und dann habe ich mich da hingesetzt und ihre Füsse waren direkt neben meinem Bein.
Und dann habe ich so ein bisschen so ein, noch nichts gesagt, weil meine Toleranzkrise, damit ich überhaupt erst was anspreche, ist sehr hoch.
Deswegen erst mal so.
Und dann wirklich, können Sie bitte Ihre Füsse wegnehmen?
Und dann sie so, auch wirklich die Füsse runter.
Ach schade. What? Nimm die Fülle? Und ich dachte mir, was ist denn hier los? Habe ich gerade den schlimmsten Menschen der Welt mir gegenüber? Die unangenehmste Person, die dann wirklich so, wirklich die Füsse runter? Ach, schade. Und dann hat sie ein Buch gelesen, irgendwie den Titel des Buches, und der Untertitel des Buches war Ein kulinarischer Krimi. Wo ich mir dachte, ey, einfach wirklich direkt Gulag, einfach so, du kannst weg sind. Wenn du das einfach wegsagen können, das Buch schade. Besser wäre es, wenn ich mir auf dem Buch verstehe, so sind sie ein sympathischer Mensch oder so, wenn so ein Lebensratgeber. Das hat doch jemand gemacht, glaube ich, in New York in der Strassenbahn oder in der U-Bahn, der ist mit gefakten Buchcovern immer in die öffentlichen Verkehrsmittel angetreten, wie man mit einem riesigen Penis lebt und sowas. Fand ich auch sehr nah an der Realität, aber es ist eine schöne Nummer. Wie machst du es persönlich? Jeder Tag ist ein Anschlag, auf mich persönlich auch. Aber man muss einfach einen guten Schneider finden, dann geht das. Also, mal kurz die Frage. Fragt das man eigentlich gerade schon? Ja, ja. Mal kurz die Frage, sind denn eigentlich die Hoden proportional zum Penis?
Also hat jemand einen grossen Penis, hat auch gleich ziemlich grosse Hoden?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Da fehlt mir die Datengrundlage.
Wie ist da das Verhältnis?
Mir fehlen da die Referenzen. Ich glaube,
die Hodenlänge oder Tiefe,
die wächst mit dem Alter auch, im Gegensatz zum Penis,
das war ja ein Vorteil. Aber wenn man Filme
guckt im Internet, dann fällt einem manchmal auf, dass es
Sachen gibt, dass dann
Sachen
die Bälle grösser als
Vielen Dank. ein Penis, das war ja ein Vorteil. Aber wenn man Filme guckt im Internet, dann fällt einem manchmal auf, dass es Sachen gibt, dass dann Sachen... Die Bälle grösser als der Kugel und die... Geh mal in die Flipchart vielleicht. Das ist eine Flipchart, wir müssen das mal wieder. Jetzt zeig dir das doch mal an. Vielleicht könnt ihr das dann enhanced podcast-mäßig als Bilder noch anschlippen. Der Herr Nachtheim braucht für seine Präsentation noch ein bisschen einen Poderationskoffer. Aber dann zeig's der Flipchart einfach. Blut. Zeig's aber schon nochmal, also der Hoden ist ein Phänomen, weil du hast ja auch, also du hast ja dann auch verschieden, verschieden tief hängende Hoden. Auch mit dem Grund, weil, also erstmal ist das Gebild ja mein Blowing, weil die Hoden dürfen nicht so warm werden, deswegen hat der Körper das aufgesourcet,ourcen mehr clever woher weiss der körper eigentlich dass es außerhalb des körpers wärmer ist als drinnen das ist doch ein rassismus die afrikaner sagen ja leute evolution nicht rassismus außen wo ist der unterschied da muss die jetzt kommst du erst mal oj simpson ja was ist mit oj simpson wenn der hoden sagt das Simpson ist immer. Okay, du meinst, wenn er grössere Hände gehabt hätte, dann hätte er es nicht gemacht. Was kommt jetzt? Ich weiss auch nicht. Wochenlang nur die Hände in die Sauna gegangen, bevor der Handschuh anzogen hat. Ich weiss nicht. Und dann plötzlich, dann krisselt er sich so ein manchmal. Da habe ich nicht genau verstanden, wann das er war. Der Hoden, nicht O.J. Simpson. Ich wollte noch die Brücke zu haben. Ich meine schon, ich bin schon immer noch bei O.J. Simpson. Gut. Aber nee, der Hoden, der krisselt sich so ein, wenn es kalt ist. Oder? Und wann noch? Auch bei der ganz lustigen Struktur. Wie alte Männer. Aber tatsächlich, ich habe mal mit der Rezeptionistin eines Urologen telefoniert, und die hat den Satz gesagt, der Hoden ist immer der Erste, der es mitkriegt. Egal was passiert in deinem Körper. Heisst ein Arzt bei den Hoden?
Nein, egal was passiert, also wenn du irgendwie mit dem Kopf irgendwo anschlägst, zuckt dein Hoden.
Sieht er sich so zusammen.
Immer, egal was passiert, der Hoden ist immer der Erste, der reagiert, weil der irgendwie so zentral im Nervenzentrum liegt oder irgendwie sowas.
Der muss ja immer beschützt werden.
Weil der einfach reflexartig sich einzieht und sagt, scheiße, jetzt kommen die Pfeile des Gegners, die dürfen meinen Hoden nicht treffen.
Also der neue Sinnspruch, solange der Hoden nicht zuckt, ist alles okay.
Warum hast du beim Urologen angerufen?
Um genau diese Frage zu klären.
Nur deswegen.
Aber ich habe mit der Rezeptionistin des Urologen gesprochen.
Ich habe mal eine Erfahrung gemacht vor einiger Zeit mit einer Rezeptionistin vom Urologen, weil es war so, dass ich einen Test gemacht hatte. Einfach mal, man will ja Sachen wissen. Länge einfach mal. Ist das alles noch okay? Ich glaube, mein Lineal ist falsch. Wie aktiv sind meine Jungs? Messen Sie das mal nach. Man macht ja manchmal so, man will ja mal einfach so wissen, was so, ne, man ist ja schon 30. Fruchtbarkeit, oder? Einfach, Fruchtbarkeit? Ne, so Geschlechtskrankheiten, Kram. So einfach mal so ein Rundum-Test.
Und ich hatte das auf Hepatitis B, C, HIV und Chlamydien.
Das waren so meine vier Anlaufpunkte.
Merkt man nicht, wenn man HIV-krank ist?
Weiß ich nicht.
Nee, merkt man das nicht sofort.
Am Grabstein, wo das irgendwas falsch läuft.
Das muss ja ausbrechen erst mal.
Merkt man das nicht, wenn man so langsam so weg,
einfach so aus der Realität wegschwappt.
Okay, Stefan war anscheinend noch nie HIV-krank. Ja, okay, ja, das ist ja. Entschuldige, das tut er gar nicht. Aber er ist noch ein bisschen jung. Wie stellst du dir das vor, Alter, wenn man aus der Realität wegtrimmt? Mir wurde ... Mami ist ein bisschen schwindlig. Heute ist total warm. Er wollte den Tod in Richtung Jenseitsgeg machen. Aber mir wurde als Kind gesagt, im Kindergarten, irgendwann kam auch mal so ein Aids-Bus an, und hat uns dann erklärt, wie Aids funktioniert. Die haben Aids verteilt, oder was? Da haben wir schon mal ein Thema mit irgendeinem Gast hier. Wow. Und dann habe ich irgendeinen Mitkindergartenkollegen gefragt, hör mal, was ist eigentlich genau Aids? Und dann hat er gesagt, dann blutest du aus jeder Öffnung des Körpers. Und dann, ich habe bis 14 oder so, habe ich geglaubt, wenn du Aids hast, dann blutest du einfach aus. Du blutest das Ding. Aber was ist ein Auge auch ein Öffnung? Ja, ja. Im technischen Sinne? Ja, der hat es so geschrieben. Im All-Sinne? Die Poren? Der fünfjährige Junge, mit dem ich gesprochen habe. Natürlich. Ist der Po eine Öffnung? Ich meinte zwar die Poren, aber der Po ist natürlich eine Öffnung. Der Popo ist eine Öffnung. Also das Poloch ist eine Öffnung. Der Po an sich.
Der fünfjährige Junge zählte auch das Poloch dazu.
Zu den Öffnungen.
Wahrscheinlich auch den Nabel.
Nicht so ganz.
Soll ich noch kurz erzählen, was die Rezeptionisten...
Ja, das war toll.
Dann muss man ja vier Wochen warten, weil dann gibt es ja die Ergebnisse.
Dann ruft man, hab ich da angerufen und wollte den Arzt sprechen.
Dann habe ich gesagt, ja, hier ist der Herr Nachtsheim.
Ich wollte mal fragen, wie die Ergebnisse entsetzt. Ach, Herr oben gezogen und dann habe ich da angerufen hat er mir das gesagt und sagt ja also heiv heiv war es glaube ich nicht mehr was nicht irgendwas mit h irgendwas ist halt so am handy und also hepatitis b war es ich glaube es war heber die ne heber die das b war es auch im hintergrundgrund hörst du alle so Blätterrauschen und bist so, alter, fick dich, Hepatitis C, nee, war es auch nicht, ja nach zwei Jahren, das war eine Klamydien, hast du ja mein Klamydien, ich war so, Moment, was, und so total schockiert gewesen und total so, was muss ich denn machen, sie hat das aber so gesagt, als hätte ich beim Zonk das richtige Tor erwischt, so Tor drei mit dem Auto, sie haben Klamydien, Glückwunsch. Bei der Auswahl ist es auch der Hauptgewinn kritisch. Ich war dann erstmal so, ich hatte natürlich, und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, aber dann muss ich ja zum Arzt, dann muss ich doch wissen, was ich da machen muss, was macht man denn da? Ja, dann nimmt man Antibiotika, und ich war so, okay, okay, dann muss ich ja vorbeikommen. Dann habe ich drei Wochen in dem Glauben gelebt, ich hätte Chlamydien, und dann bin ich zum Arzt gegangen, das war eine sehr persönliche Geschichte, aber ist egal, aber auf jeden Fall bin ich dann zum Arzt gegangen und saß dann dort und hab gewartet und geschwitzt und die drei Wochen waren dann wirklich die Hölle so. Dann gehst du zum Arzt rein und dann sag ich so, ich war halt wirklich so, ich hatte schon mein Testament eigentlich in der Tappe und bin rein und ich so, ja, guten Tag, ich wollte mal fragen, wie das jetzt so ist und er so, ist doch alles super. Und ich war so, wie das alles super, ja ist doch super, Sie haben nix. Was war Chlamydien? Was war Chlamydien? Sie haben Chlamydien? Habe ich Chlamydien? Ja, haben Sie keine Chlamydien?
Habe ich denn jetzt klamydien was
mit den klamydien sie haben klamydien haben sie keine klamydien habe ich denn jetzt klamydien
nicht haben keine guckte aus platten sagt sie haben keine klamydien hat sich einfach die
Rezeptionisten vergriffen ich hatte drei Wochen lang im Glauben geblieben dass ich klamydien
hatte und habe einfach habe einfach wirklich und du bist da gehst ja auch so die Vergangenheit
im Kopf und du denkst schon so okay wie weit du musst ja Leuten auf was bescheiden musst ja gut
aber auf der anderen Seite läuft da draußen irgendwo ein Max-Tagsheim rum, der jetzt Klamydien hat, aber die falsche Akte bekommen hat. Ja, wahrscheinlich. Und es nicht weiss. Ja. Oh, wie unangenehm ist das. Weil der Geburt verwechselt. Fuck. Ich stelle mir nur vor, wie diese Unterlagen aussehen müssen, so ein Totenschädel immer drauf, ja, der hat HIV, der hat HIV, der hat, der hat, aber hier, Klamydien. Hi-V und dann so ein trauriger Smiley. Ja, doch kann man ja sein, dass man sowas sagt zu jemandem, und das darf sie auch nicht am Telefon eigentlich.
Nee, vor allem mit so einer Naivität.
Ja, Sie haben Chlamydien!
So ein DSDS-Marco Schreil dahin zu setzen. Sie haben Chlamydien? Vielleicht!
Nicht nach der Werbung.
Das hören Sie nach diesem Kurs Musik.
Vor der Werbung haben Sie gesehen, dass Herr Nachtsahn sehr angespannt war.
Wir brauchen mehr Sendezeit, wir müssen noch mehr Spannung aufbauen. Was war das wichtigste Telefonat eures Lebens? Vor der Werbung haben Sie gesehen, dass Herr Nachts dann sehr angespannt war.
Brauchen wir Sendezeit, wir müssen noch mehr Spannung aufbauen. Was war das wichtigste Telefonat eures Lebens? Kannst du uns eine Sekunde geben und vorlegen mit deiner? Weil da müssen wir drüber nachdenken, glaube ich. Das ist spannend. Das ist natürlich mega clever als Podcaster, das zu sagen. Deswegen bin ich froh, dass du mal hier bist bei uns. Das ist nur der Trick, nur der Trick. Nur alter Trick. Natürlich habe ich das aber noch nie begriffen,
beziehungsweise Mind-Bäu, weil natürlich hat er einen im Kopf, sonst würde er das Thema ja nicht ansteigen. Nee, habe ich tatsächlich nicht. Es wäre am smartesten, wenn du eine hättest. Ja, das stimmt. Aber ich habe auch oft gehofft, jetzt. Es ist schon wichtig, also im Sinne von Beziehungen irgendwie so, man hat sich lange nicht gesehen, man kommt wieder in Kontakt, man telefoniert wieder und denkt sich, okay, funktioniert das noch, das ist schon sehr aufregend. Aber ich habe auch mal angerufen, um herauszufinden, ob ich bei einer Schauspielschule genommen wurde, bei der Schauspielschule, wo ich immerhin wollte, mein ganzes Leben lang, an die Otto-Falkenberg-Schule in München. Und dann war ich da bevorsprechen, habe vorgesprochen und dann hieß es so, ja, rufen Sie an und dann ist er irgendwie so ein Erstemeister Schauspielstudent, sitzt dann halt von einer langen Liste, wo er dann irgendwie Leben zerstört, Leben zerstört, Leben zerstört halt überall stand.
Macht noch eine Spalte für, hat er geweint, ja, nein.
Ja, genau. Und dann rufst du halt an so, ja, guten Tag, hallo, hier Florentin Will.
Dann so, ja, Florentin Will.
Nee, schon sehr stark.
Abgelehnt.
Okay. Tschüss.
Okay, dann.
Stellt ihr mir sonst noch was?
Nö.
Und bei Ihnen so. Und der hat das Telefon nicht beendet.
Okay, dann... Also, sonst noch was? Nö. Und der hat das Telefon nicht beendet. Und ich so, okay, dann... Dann lege ich jetzt auf. Okay, ich wollte es nicht wahrhaben, und dann habe ich aufgelegt. Es ist nicht so ganz spektakulär, aber für den war das die maximale Langeweile. So einfach so eine Lisse abgehen und, oh fuck, irgendwie, okay, gut, nein, nein, nein. Aber der hat da einfach mit seiner gelangweilten Erstsemesterstimme einfach Träume zerstört und Euphorien ausgelöst, bei manchen den genommen worden. Vor allen Dingen bei Ja dann vielleicht noch so und wir schicken ihn dann die Unterlagen zu, das hört der andere. Ja genau, jawoll, ruft vielleicht nochmal an, um das zu klären, aber der erste Moment ist der Freude. Ihr müsst nicht antworten, ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich wurde mal angerufen, da mir gesagt, K1 hasst dich. In so einer verzerrten Stimme. Das war unser Labelchef, der wollte mir sagen, dass wir, ja, ist egal. Stimmt das eigentlich, wenn man in Tassen spricht? In manchen Filmen spricht man in Tassen, wenn die die Stimme verstellen wollen. Nee, so eine Krawatte hält man vor. Ja, Krawatte und so eine Tasse. Hängt so ein Strick an. Dann haben die so eine Münztelefone. Tasse drunter und reden die rein. Hilft das irgendwas oder haben die einfach nur, waren die sehr durstig dabei und wollten immer was trinken? Gab es nicht diesen einen genialen Fall, wo irgendjemanden umgebracht hat, ein kleines Kind umgebracht, dann irgendwie so, oh, der ist weg. Sorry, vorbei. Und dann haben die einen Zeitungsartikel gedruckt, wo die geschrieben haben, oh, Kind ist tot. Ja. Und dann hat sich tatsächlich der Mörder zu Wort gemeldet, hat gesagt, Freunde, pass mal auf. Ist noch gar nicht tot. Atme noch. Und der wollte so, weil es gibt ja manchmal so Serienmörder, die genießen dann auch die Aufmerksamkeit und spielen dann so mit den Medien so Zodiac, schicken dann so versteckte Botschaften. Und der dachte, er ist ganz clever und er schickt der Presse ein Bild von sich, aber mit so einem Bildeffekt bearbeitet, so einem Strudel, dass der so eingedreht ist, dass man ihn nicht erkennt und dachte so, ihr findet nie, wer es ist und die Polizei halt einfach straight Effekt umdrehen, whoop, reverse, zack, gefurten, verhaftet, down, einfach so, der hat sich so clever gefühlt, so, erger, mich kriegt der nie und er so, Moment mal, und Apfel Z, okay, haben wir, gut, du da drüben, verhaftet, verhaftet-Partei mit Dinglechse einfach. Aber der wird auch im Gefängnis sitzen am Tag und denkt sich, du von Idiot einfach. Der wird das nicht gerafft haben, der hat einfach mit einem Zelt insass, noch erzählt, ich weiß nicht, wie sie es geschafft hat, die besten Leute an dem. Ich bin so genial bei Photoshop. Er hätte einfach ein Emoji drüberlegen können, das hätte alles smarter gewesen als das. Wow, das mit dem Emoji ist so richtig asozial, fährt man gerade auf. Ja, und das ist auch noch der Weinsmiley. Nein, nein, nein, der Smiley mit den Affen, der so macht. Ja. Und das über das Gesicht eines Mörders, der so, oh, ha, ha, ha, hups. Gibt es eigentlich so ein Smiley, so Finger vor dem Mund? Ja. Echt? Es gibt auch Nachdenken. Oh, da, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi. Du hast den Experten eingeladen hier. Max kennt jeden Smiley. Dußer Emoji-Hater. Es gibt eine grosse Liste von Hass-Emojis, es gibt Emojis, die sind super. Ich finde zum Beispiel, dass der Tränen-Smiley, der steht für mich für das absolut dümmste Lachen, was man verschicken kann. Also dieses so stark Lachen, dass man weint. Das ist ein Podcast, ne? Das ist ja schon... Wir fügen ein Foto bei. Du musst für die Webcam das wohl jetzt fünf Minuten lang machen. Gebt mal ein, 86684.jpg, könnt ihr finden. Ja, aber der Grund, warum ihr hier seid, ist natürlich, dass wir Jubiläum ... Kommen wir mal zum Thema. Die fünftzigste Folge. Yeah, fünfzig! Fünftzigste Folge, Poffo. Happy Birthday! Was habt ihr uns denn mitgebracht? Habibt es ein Geschenk, gibt es eine Rede? Was hat euch denn so ein bisschen... Schönes Bild machen. Das ist ja gar so kein Blüten hinterlassen. Das ist euch besonders gefallen. Was war denn eure Lieblingsfolge der letzten 50 Folgen? Ich fühl mich gerade so ein bisschen... Die, wo ich zu Gast war, war super. Die habe ich auch gehört. Ehrlich? Ja, so halb, glaube ich. Aber ich fühl mich gerade ein bisschen wie die Freunde meiner Eltern, die am Tag meiner Erstkommunion einfach zusätzlich eingeladen waren, gar nicht wussten, dass ich Erstkommunion habe und die so, was ist denn hier so für ein Boheir und so viele Leute da? Ich habe Erstkommunion. Nee, du hättest sagen müssen, das ist immer so. Ich habe das total nach Iva beantwortet und die so, oh, der Geldbeutel direkt aus der Tasche, dann gebe ich dir mal Geld. Genauso fühle ich mich jetzt gerade. Und die hat ihr ihr gesamtes Geld gegeben? Ja, alles klar, ich hätte eine Waffe. Ihr seid so richtig unruhige Pickler beide, ihr habt beide diese... Er hat einen Limonaddeckel. Das mache ich immer, ja, das mache ich immer. Ich mache das auch immer. Ich schaffe das nicht, es sind diese Charity-Kleine Flaschen, und die haben, wenn man das Ding aufmacht, den Deckel aufmacht, haben die so kleine Verschluss... Ich tue mir da immer weh und ich mache die auch immer ab. Ich mache genau das gleiche wie ihr.
Ich mache die ab, aber dann teile ich sie manchmal in Hälfte und manchmal in Drittel.
Aber das ist beim Podcast ein ganz schlimm.
Warum machen wir das?
Man braucht irgendwas, was du ein Fingernägelkauer.
Gar nicht, überhaupt nicht.
Ich bin ganz schlimm.
Manchmal, wenn ich Auto fahre, bis auf den Knochen.
Echt?
Ja, krass.
Nach langen Strecken muss er aber auf die Notaufnahme, weil Blutverlust.
Tatsächlich, aber ich bin wirklich, also jetzt gerade geht's, aber ich bin manchmal ganz, ganz schlimm.
Nägelkauer und Abkauer. Bei mir ist es immer so, ich verstehe
Nägel zu einem gewissen Grad,
dass man, wenn man die stutzt, dann
wachsen die nach, weil die von hinten
nachgedrückt werden, aber die kommen ja von hinten,
also die werden von hinten nach vorne gedrückt.
Aber ich denke mir so, was ist, wenn der ganze
Nagel weg ist?
Kommt dann noch was nach?
Oder ist das dann auch irgendwann mal Schluss? Oder braucht neu an oder die veranlagungen sind ja da die veranlagungen sind tief im daumen sind die etwas getroffen worden früher bei der geburt hat man gesagt ab hier ist jetzt immer daumennagel und wenn du da einmal beispiel ich habe ich habe mich an silvester ganz ganz schlimm verbrannt ganz schlimm verbrannt hier auf Hier auf dem Nagelrücken. Wegen Schienerböller? Am Fondue oder am Böller? Sei ich ehrlich. Oder emotional oder finanziell. Pizzaofen? Fondue. Wirklich Fondue? Nein, es war ein Silvesterböller. Es war ein Fingernfett. Ein rebellen Polenbott. Nein, es war einfach so ein Zisselmännchen. Ich finde es schön, wie du angefangen hast mit der Autoritätserklärstimme, das mache ich auch so oft, und dann auf einmal alle demontieren dich. Aber man belädt sich auch ein, eins zu demontieren eigentlich. Ja, klar. So, und dann seitdem habe ich so eine Delle im Nagel, die sieht man auch noch, die wächst sich so langsam raus und die wächst wesentlich langsamer jetzt als der andere Nagel. Heißt, der war komplett zerstört innerlich und dann hat sich einfach, wenn man sich den Nagel als sozusagen als Kreis vorstellt, so eine Kreisoberfläche, hat sich so eine kleine Delle eingeschleust. Und die wird jetzt so langsam weggedrückt. Aber die bleibt, die wandert halt so raus. Und das hat es verlangsamt. Heißt, ist scheißegal. Wie viel Kraft hat denn ein Fingernagelwachstum? Also angenommen, du würdest dich jetzt mit deinem Fingernagel gegen die Wand stemmen, und dann wächst der, und kann der dich dann drücken, also kann der dich wegdrücken mit dem Wacken, oder wie stark, kann man dem mit Kraft zu sehen? Starkes Wasser, super stark, stark genug. Ich glaube, das ist richtig stark, oder? Stark genug bestimmt schon, aber der Nagel selber hält ja nichts aus. Also meine sind sehr weich, die biegen sich sofort um. Aber stell dir mal so Bruce Lee vor, der so auf Fingern Liegestützen machen kann, und der macht Liegestützen auf all seinen Fingernägeln. Können die ihnen dann so nach oben wachsen? Ja, das ist der Bruce Lee. Gibt's noch einen Film von ihm? Nee, die bin der Nagel, der die Tigerkralle des Nagels oder so. Die goldene Palme von Kahn, den goldenen Nagel gewonnen. Aber vielleicht ist es nicht, weil es gibt ja so eine... Die sind Kammern, der sowieso Nails... Es gibt ja so eine Hinrichtungsmethode irgendwo im Dschungel von so Dschungelstämmen oder so. Mit Bambus? Genau, mit Bambus.
Oh, das ist grausam.
Die dann so ein Bambus an dich dran und dann wächst der Bambus durch dich durch, wo ich mir auch immer dachte.
Er wurde auch in Deutschland versagt, aber das funktioniert, aber in Deutschland, die mit einer Eiche, das verhungert vorher.
Das kann man so ein Ordnungsamt davor sagen. Was machen Sie hier?
Kleiner Funfact, die Nägel wachsen genauso schnell, wie der Mond sich von der Erde entfernt.
Seit wann entfernt sich der Mond und von der Erde?
Ja, das ist ein aktuelles Problem.
Das ist ein Problem.
Lass es mal ein bisschen auf...
Der Mega krass gerade raus, Alter.
Das muss ich auch nicht immer...
Du musst dich ja immer alles ironisch kommentieren.
Das ist so krass in meinem Kopf, das ist so ein Äpfchen, das Tarn.
Das ist ihre Meta-Improv-Schiene, das Thema läuft gerade aus.
Egal, hier ist noch eins, hier sind noch drei, komm, mach mal 14.
Wir wollen bei den Nägeln, das passt.
Ja, also Jesus wäre das obligatorische nächste Thema. Ich gucke uns gerade viel zu lange in die Augen, Florian. Das ist wirklich keine Chlamydien? Du kannst mir sagen, ich muss eh. Wie kann man Chlamydien übertragen, außer... Das weiß ich nicht. Ich habe mich auch gefragt, ich habe mich ja nicht mehr damit beschäftigt. Aber was machen dann... Wir können tief... Wo ist die Frage? Wir wollen mit allen Gästen... Das ist aber auch immer ein super Einstiegsthema, die Chlamydien-Geschichte. Mit jedem Gast, der heute da war, hat man auch das Thema Geschlechtskrankheit. Vielleicht soll ich das Mikro desinfizieren. Ich habe auch was dabei. Aber da geht es kaputt, ne? Hast du heute schon so viel über Geschlechtskrankheit geredet? Hatte einer welche? Andi Lynch war da, der hat bestimmt welche. Oh, das stimmt schon. Du hast in der Tasche ein Desinfektionsspray. Ich bin Bahn gefahren, ohne mache ich das nicht. War's echt? Ich gehe ab und zu mal gerne aufs Klo, wenn ich fünf Stunden Bahn fahre und nebel ich vorher die ganze Hütte ein. Wenn ich schon eine Geschlechtskrankheit kriegen würde, dann möchte ich vorher auch Spaß haben und nicht nur aufs Klo gegangen sein. Das ist wirklich das deprimierendste, wenn du so jemand bist, der gar kein Sexualleben hat und dann hast du trotzdem immer Geschlechtskrankheit, weil du einfach zu lange auf der Bahnhofstleute warst. Und dann gibst du für deinen Freund noch an, ich hab jetzt auch Chlamydien, und wer war es? Die Bahn. Was soll das denn? Cool. Es ist ein bisschen so, wenn du dich outest, aber dann keinen Freund findest. Ja. Ja, eben können. Oder? Versteht ihr so ein bisschen, was ich meine? Ja, ja, ja. Dann ist man zwar schwul, aber man denkt sich, ja, aber... Da habe ich den ganzen Akt hier gemacht und jetzt komme ich nicht zu mir. Warum hätte ich das einfach lassen können? Ja, vor allem dann ist ja so ein Erwartungswahl, weil plötzlich ist seine Sexualität so öffentlich und jeder weiß, ah, okay, der steht auf Männer in unserem Fall. Und dann denkt man sich, ja, aber jetzt los, Freundchen. Und dann so, ja, dann stirbst du alleine. Dann denkst du dir, dann hättest du ja auch sparen können, nicht zu outen, oder? Also ist es mega homophob, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Aber als hättest du wieder heterosexuell.
Es ist, als hättest du Erdkunde studiert und danach, ach so, ich krieg keinen Job, wenn ich Erdkunde studiere und nicht Lehramt. Aber was ich ja immer noch mega lustig fände, wäre so ein zurückgenommenes Outing, dass man dann irgendwann mal sagt, so Leute, ich bin doch nicht schwul. Das denke ich mir bei den Verkaufsgeschwestern, die früher mein Bruder waren, wo der eine
die Geschlechtsumwandlung gemacht hat und der andere gesagt hat, ne, ich warte noch ein bisschen. Warum nutzt der den Moment dann nicht auch? Er hat vielleicht mal gedacht, guck mal du, wie das medizinisch läuft, und du damit klarkommst, sag mir mal die besten Ärzte, ich guck mal, wie das läuft, und dann vielleicht. Dass die sich auch so einig waren da drin, dass beide das machen wollen. Eben, aber dass die einen nicht sofort mitzieht und dass die Filme einfach auch objektiv schlechter werden, da es Frauen sind. Ja gut, Cloud Atlas war aber noch gut. Cloud Atlas war überhaupt nicht gut. Ich fand den noch gut. Nee, aber Max... Matrix Reloaded bleibt das Meisterwerk. Das ist die beste Komödie, die ich in dem Jahr gesehen habe. Reloaded ist noch okay, oder? Reloaded ist okay, Revolution. Nein, Reloaded ist eigentlich auch schon schwierig. Ich war ja auch kein Fan des ersten Teil. Die meisten Zwillinge und so, Schlüsselmeister. Ich war kein Fan. Geile Action-Serie. Die sind immer wieder auf einander zufahren. Und Mr. Smith war damals auch cool. Heute halt CGI, CGI altert halt nicht so. Und dann kannst du heute gucken und denkst, der lame. Aber damals? Was ist los mit Serien? Zu viel. Komm nicht das Serien-Thema. Jeder redet gerade über Serien, ne? Aber es ist auch echt... Nicht gerade, oder? Wir sind ja derselben Podcast bei... Wann hört das wieder auf? Weiß ich nicht. Ist er ein Trend? Ist er ein schlimmer Trend? Ich würde nicht. Aber ist es ein Trend? Auf jeden Fall, also doch, es ist ein Podcast ein Trend.
Ja, aber Kino ist auch nicht wirklich ein Trend. Ja, aber vor zehn Jahren, guck mal, da warst du so, okay, es gibt Lost, es gibt Prison Break und dann war schon so Dexter. Ja, Simpsons. Doug. Okay, Doug. King of Queens oder was? Nein, nicht Doug. Kannst du die Melodie von Doug aus dem Stehgreif nachsingen? Aber ...
Das war alles so ...
Mit Pettin und Leser. Zum Stehgreif nachsingen. Aber ... Das war alles so ...
Mit Patty Mayonnaise.
Danke, Fanny.
Mit Patty Mayonnaise, klar.
Ey, ich like Patty Mayonnaise auf Facebook.
Nein.
Liked alle Patty Mayonnaise auf Facebook.
Das ist die beste Facebook-Seite.
Patty Mayonnaise, hallo?
Patty Mayonnaise.
Wie ist er wohl dein bester Freund?
Flash?
Nee, wie ...
Skeeter.
Gordon war der Böse?
Wie hieß der der Böse?
Ja, Gordon.
Aber früher hattest du doch eine Serienlandschaft und da hat sich auch was abgelöst. Ich meine, die Simpsons haben Cosby gekillt, bevor jeder wusste, dass Cosby eh nicht so cool ist. Ich finde es immer so lustig, dass es so böse, also offensichtlich böse in so Kinderfilmen gibt, wie auch bei Dark, die ja nicht böse sein können, weil sie ja immer auch in so einem Schwulcosmos sind. Also, vielleicht ein einfacheses Beispiel bei Harry Potter, die Slytherins. Die sind ja eigentlich nicht böse. Die sind, na ja, eben genau, und die werden im letzten Teil, werden die in die Kerker gesperrt, weil die, nachdem die sich irgendwie von, weiss ich nicht, dieser Umbridge oder so befreit haben, werden einfach die ganzen Slytherins in die Kerker gesperrt, wo ich mir denke, wow, das sind Schüler eurer Schule, und die werden einfach so weggesperrt. Wenn sie sich böse verhalten, sind sie doch böse Schüler. Es sind aber nicht alle Slytherin-Slytherin-Slytherin. Und der Typ, der Gordon ist doch ein böser Typ, weil er der Bulli ist auf dem Schulhof und die ganze Zeit da kommt seine Freunde. Und Skeeter ärgert. Keiner ärgert Skeeter. Ja. Keiner ärgert Skeeter, dann wird Max böse. Und will immer Pettin-Mayonnaise-Ganam machen, aber sie will nicht. Erklär mir mal ganz kurz, du bist Fan von so Actionfiguren und Sammelfiguren. Ja. Erklär mir mal ganz kurz die Faszination, so was ist daran geil? Oder kann man das nicht verstehen, wenn man da nicht drin ist? Ich glaube, das kann man nicht verstehen. Sammelst du Sachen, sammelst du irgendwas Spezifizier? Ich habe früher immer so Warhammer-Figuren, aber mit denen kann man auch spielen und die bemalen und so. Fusseln sammelst du, deinem T-Shirt nachzuurteilen. Ich dachte jetzt kurz, irgendwie war so ein Gänk, so ein Koffer ein. Willst du gerade der Bösewicht dieses Podcast werden? Ja, ja, ich will, das ist nämlich mit Kackerspern. Augenringe, wenn man sich da... Ja, ich auch. Ich fand es immer ganz toll, Sachen, von den Dingen, die ich geliebt habe, zum Beispiel wenn ich die Ghostbusters ganz toll fand als Cartoon-Serie, fand ich es ganz toll, dass dieser wie der Spass nachdem die Serie vorbei war und dann konnte ich mir den, also ich konnte mein eigenes Ghostbusters-Erlebnis haben, deswegen fand ich Actionfiguren immer total toll und ich fand immer schön zu sehen, wie die Interpretation einer Figur aussieht, die man in einer Serie sieht oder in einem Film, was du daraus machen kannst. 3D. Der 3D-Drucker, habt ihr euch schon mal 3D scannen lassen und drucken lassen? Das kann man jetzt machen im Mediamarkt. Ich würde nicht wissen, wie ich gucken soll. Es gibt auch so eine geile Szene im neuen Film, da rausgekommen ist, Einsamkeit und Sex und Mitleid, den die Firma hier mitproduziert hat. Also ein grosser Tipp daraus. Und da gibt's eine mega geile Szene, wie sich ein Paar, was sich kurz danach trennt, 3D-scannen lässt als Actionfigur, aber halt Geschlechtsverkehr hat während des Scans und dann danach einfach ... und dann sie gerade während des Scans mit ihm Schluss macht und später dann nochmal diese Figur zum Tragen kommt. Ich will das jetzt nicht spoilern, aber es ist eine mega coole Szene. Ist das aber, funktioniert das? Ich glaube nicht. Immer wenn ich oben im Saturnman in Frankfurt, da sitzt da immer so ein Typ und der sieht immer super beschäftigt aus. Ich glaube, er guckt einfach nur Tiervideos auf YouTube und ist völlig irritiert, dass keiner diesen Quatsch macht. Moment, er muss dann still sitzen oder was? Und wenn du dich bewegst, dann hat die Figur am Ende acht Arme. Ja, du kannst es doch eigentlich schauen. Viel cooler, wenn deine Figur acht Arme hat. Du kannst dir so einen Helm machen, wenn du ganz schnell um deinen Kopf bewegst die ganze Zeit. Das ist das Coolste, was dir einfällt, dir einen Helm aus deinen eigenen Händen zu machen. Ja, was denn sonst? Fünfzig Arme haben, Helm aus deinen Händen, ein Handhelm. Wow, Stefan. Er wird nicht Autor, Kreativgenieur, Stefan Thiel. Ein Handhelm. Okay, Kreativgenieur. 50 coolere Sachen als ein Handhelm. Er ist gleichzeitig Helm und deine Hände. Ja, eben. Danke, dass du das nicht verstehst. Nee. Okay, dann eure Top-Eins, bitte jetzt mal, der Dinger, die, die, die, die, die im 3D-Scan dann machen können. Also wenn du keine Selbstscham hast, so wie wir alle am Tisch jetzt, ziehst du einfach dein T-Shirt aus und babbelst mit deinem Fett hin und er, dass die Nippel hin und er standen und hast du ganz breite Nippel und ganz komischen Torso. Wie ist das besser als ein Hemd, Helm? Ein Handhelm, du weißt schon nicht mehr, wie es heißt. Das ist eine Form, weil du hast sehr viele Nippel.
Sehr viele Hände, sehr lange Nippel auch.
Nein, ich habe gar ekelig.
Niemand hat gesagt, es darf nicht eklig sein.
Ich glaube, ich würde mich ganz schnell auf der Stelle umdrehen,
dann habe ich so Gesicht vorne und hinten.
Wenn ich einen sehr großen Penis hätte, würde ich so einen Helikopter machen,
dann hätte ich so eine Platte davor.
Oder so eine Schale, da kannst du eine Erdnuss erraten,
wenn du sie auf dem Rücken liegst.
Endlich mal eine sinnvolle Einsatz für den Rücken.
Aber ich will jemanden sehen, der auf dem Rücken liegt und den Propeller kann.
Oder auch die Das ist die ganze Zeit, dann hätte ich so eine Platte davor. Oder so eine Schale, da kannst du Erdnuss rein tun, wenn du so auf dem Rücken liegst. Endlich mal eine sinnvolle Einsatz für die Nummer. Aber ich will jemanden sehen, der auf dem Rücken liegt und den Propeller kann. Oh, das ist nicht schlecht. Und dann abhebt. Der liegt dann im Saturn eine halbe Stunde auf dem Boden und lässt sich scannen. Aber ist das verboten, dann Nacktscans? Nein, das habe ich noch nicht beklärt. Ich will ehrlich gesagt, du wissen wie der Mitarbeiter reagiert aus solchen München. Aber ist sich eigentlich im 3D-Scanner scannen und das Leuten schenken das neue, ich mache ein schlechtes Fotoshooting beim Dorffotografen, ist das jetzt so die coole Variante? Das ist eine Überraschungsscan von denen, so während sie schlafen und da irgendwie einen Saturn tragen. Wir waren ja mal zusammen bei ihm um die Ecke im Copyshop, der ja auch so in der Zeit festgefroren ist, in den späten 90ern. Der Rottger im Copyshop. Da hängen natürlich immer noch diese T-Shirts von Leuten mit ihrem eigenen Gesicht und so was.
Und ich warte noch weiter, wie die will, dass die irgendwann 3D-Scannen bekommen.
Was ist das dann hinterher? Wundervoll. Hat ein T-Shirt mit einem Person mit einem T-Shirt drauf.
Hat ein T-Shirt drauf mit sich selbst und lässt sich dann scannen.
Das ist schon gut.
Ja.
Oder er hat so eine Figur von sich selber in der Hand und lässt sich dann scannen.
Und immer weiter, dann wird die Figur immer kleiner.
Das ist ziemlich cool eigentlich.
Matroschka.
Oh Mann, steht Matroschka.
Matussek.
Das ist der moderne Matussek.
So was will ich.
Und das wäre bis zur Decke hoch.
Ja, aber ich mag Actionfiguren, das ist gut.
Cool.
Ich fand ja dein Bild immer noch am allerlustigsten,
wo du eine Mischung aus dem Pokémon Paras
Vielen Dank. Ich fand ja dein Bild immer noch am allerlustigsten, wo du eine Mischung aus dem Pokémon Paras und Helmut Karasek gemacht hast und da hast du Helmut Parasek. Das ist so lustig. Das Pokémon hieß Parasek. Ja, nee, Paras. Die Weiterentwicklung heißt Parasek. Weiterentwicklung heißt Parasek. Ach, tatsächlich. Deswegen ist es noch eine lustigigere Woche. Stimmt. Noch ein besseres Wort. Dann finde ich es noch lustiger. Danke für diesen Hinweis. Aber dass du mehr lachen kannst, ist es gut. Ich glaube, der Eensbus ist gerade vorgefahren. Der ASB fährt hier an. Das ist eine ganz ruede Firma. Die haben Krankenwagen, die haben Busse und das war's. Ich dachte, die werden da gereinigt oder gewartet. Nee,. Die haben das Logo von denen drauf. Nein, nein, Florentin, falsch gedacht. Die haben das Logo von denen drauf. Ich habe auch nicht das Logo von meiner Reinigung die ganze Zeit auf mir drauf. Welches Gefühl löst ein solcher Reisebus in euch aus? Angst. Angst, wovor, Schulfahrt? Das war aber ein Verkehrsbus, nicht so ein Reisebus. Das war ein Reisebus aus Frankfurt. Echt? Ich dachte, das wäre so ein ... Nee, das wäre ein Reisebus aus Frankfurt. Ich glaube ... Der ist nach Bad Op gefahren, an die Uhr. So ein Geruch von Erbrochenem. Weil das war ganz schlimm, wir sind nach Kroatien gefahren. Jeder kennt das, glaube ich. 14 Stunden lang. Was ist denn Mathe? Er hat geile Felgen, Alter. Das liegt bei Pimp Ma, right? Und in Stunde eins hat Daniel in der Mitte des Busses einfach erbrochen. Das musste Daniel. Zu viel Jägermeister. Was eine blöde Idee, wenn man 14 Stunden nach Kroatien fährt. Und dann, es wurde halt immer wärmer, wenn man gen Süden fuhr und der Geruch wurde immer so schön aromatischer und schlussend saftig ist ihm die Nase gestiegen. Das war ganz schlimm. Wie lange seid ihr da gefahren? 14 Stunden. Ich bin auch mal 14 Stunden nach Italien gefahren. Das ist wirklich, das ist schon ohne Kotze unerträglich. Und musst du dir da so Sachen berechnen, so wenn wir hier losfahren und gleichzeitig der Deutsche Ekal in Paris losfährt, wann machen wir einen Unfall? Ja, der Mathe-Ek... Einfach nur damit man es irgendwie rechtfertigt. Ja, deswegen Mathe-Ekart. Ciao, jetzt viel Spaß mit St. K. Der Jägermeister war auch nur so, ich halte es nicht mehr aus, ich muss saufen, oder? Der hat so und so viel Promille, das entspricht so und so viel Sechsten. Würde ich töten, glaube ich. Wen würdest du töten? Nee, wenn ich in diesem Bus sitzen würde, Mathe, Elka, und es würden solche Ideen oft kommen. Wir berechnen jetzt alles. Direkt rausschmeissen, rauswerfen an sich selber. Wir müssen uns auch leider aufhören, schon langsam, weil ich zum Zug muss, tut mir leid. Aber auf jeden Fall, ihr könnt ja auch noch weiter reden von mir aus, aber ich sag schon mal, wir werden jetzt sowieso früher oder später mal wieder mal einen Weg laufen, hier und da. Vielen Dank, dass ihr da war, zur 50. Folge, nur deshalb hier. Ja, vielen Dank dafür. Die beiden, die hauen immer wieder gute Sprüche raus. Ich muss echt sagen, was eine tolle Folge 50, dass wir die alle bekommen konnten, dass die alle gesagt haben, Podcast-Ufo, finde ich gut, gratulieren wir mal zur Folge 50. Vielen Dank an alle, die hier waren für diese unvergessliche Podcast-Geburtstags-Gala. Aber vor allem danke an euch da draußen, denn ohne euch wären diese 50 Folgen, und ich hoffe, da kommen noch 50. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was machen wir zur Folge 100? Gute Frage. Laden wir ihn ein, mal gucken. Aber ich finde, wir sollten auf jeden Fall euch danken da draußen, denn unter euch wäre das alles nicht möglich. Ihr seid der Wind in unseren Flügeln. Und man muss auch dazu sagen, wenn es nicht so viele wären, dann hätten wir auch schon lange aufgehört. Weil ich glaube, wir sind so machtgeil. Wir sind macht und so aufmerksamkeitsgeil. Und es kommt auch einiges zurück, speziell Per toll die ganzen kommentare sind toll auch bei itunes freue mich über kommentare wenn ja noch ein paar fünf sterne wir freuen uns über t-shirt einkäufe geld spenden aber auch einfach nette worte all das ist immer gerne sehen oder auch wenn wir uns auf der strasse sehen einfach so eine fünf eine hand drücken einfach mal so lieblos im grunde ist patreon nichts anderes ja aber ich finde es gut wenn das so ein bisschen persönlicher wenn ich der Strasse seht und ich frage, wollen wir ihn ansprechen, einfach so einen Zwanni in der Hand drücken, einfach so zustecken, so in mein Hemd. Oder so in den Rucksack, wenn man es sich merkt und ein Zuhause freut er sich. Freue ich mich, ja, kommt dann auch aufs Konto. Freunde, das waren 50 fantastische Folgen des Podcast UFO. Wo wird die Reise hingehen? Wir wissen es nicht, aber wir hoffen, dass ihr mit dabei seid, wenn wir neue Sphären erreichen und fremde Galaxien bereisen.
Und bis dahin, wehme ab.